aujourd'hui on est dans le bricolage et
Gabriel Atal fait face au députés il
fait face à la nation aussi puisque son
discours de politique générale sera
diffusé partout des députés comme Fabien
Roussel le communiste qui l'attend de
pieds ferme le Premier ministre prend la
parole dans quelques instants pour fixer
donc le le cap de la politique qu'il
entend tenir on imaginait que ce serait
son son premier grand test et bien non
la contestation des agriculteurs a pris
la suite des polémiques autour de la
ministre ou ctera Gabriel Atal et
matigon de depuis à peine 3 semaines et
il semble là depuis des mois bonjour
isrard bonjour bon directeur adjoint de
la rédaction du Figaro dites-moi if
c'est un début de mission chargée pour
Gabriel Atal il s'en sort comment
jusqu'ici bah je dirais plutôt pas mal
d'ailleurs hein parce que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est chargé c'est chargé pour
plusieurs raisons euh d'abord parce que
il a pas de majorité hein il faut le
dire il a qu'une majorité relative et
donc quand vous avez une majorité
relative bah tout est plus compliqué ça
c'est la première chose la deuxème chose
c'est qu'il a un président qui euh euh
lui grille souvent la politesse ah oui
ça seulement qu'on pu dire donc il a
fait déjà une conférence de presse il y
a 15 jours le Président il va reparler
cet après-midi d'ailleurs en Suède mais
surtout jeudi sur les agriculteurs et
puis troisème chose et bien le pays va
pas très bien c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire et en plus il y a une crise
agricole une colère des agriculteurs qui
sont sur les routes et qui
euh bien réclame beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses qui sont d'ailleurs
un condensé un petit peu de ce que les
Français dans leur globalité en tous les
cas beaucoup de métiers réclam
c'est-à-dire moins de taxes moins
d'impôts plus de liberté moins de
bureaucratie et peut-être une une une
concurrence internationale plus régulée
plus contrôlée c'est ce qui c'est ce
qu'il demande deux images celle-ci
d'abord les agriculteurs alors ça c'est
sur la 4 en en scèmarne qui bloque une
autoroute et puis dans le même temps à
l'Assemblée nationale tiens Julien Bayou
ici salle des quatre colonnes les
députés arrivent progressivement dans
l'hémicycle en attendant le Premier
ministre pardon avant d'entrer sur le
fond y il est déjà marqué presque
physiquement Gabriel Atal a déjà de la
fatigue alors c'est peut-être facile
mais je me souviens que Édouard Philippe
disait par exemple à propos de lui à
propos de Manuel Vals que Premier
ministre c'était chargé quoi c'était
fatiguant oui bah on parle de l'enfer de
Matignon hein ça tout le monde sait bah
effectivement parce que vous êtes
toujours au four et au moulin vous êtes
àu et àia vous êtes sur tous les fronts
sur tous les sujets vous êtes pas
beaucoup dans pas d'expression pour dire
ça voilà vous êtes pas beaucoup sur le
long terme vous êtes beaucoup sur le
court terme parce que vous êtes obligé
de d'apporter des réponses et des
solutions immédiates donc c'est pas
évident hein c'est c'est c'est loin
d'être évident pour pour un premier
ministre ou pour une première ministre
et euh et encore une fois en plus quand
vous n'avez pas derrière vous une
majorité large soudée et que vous avez
des oppositions que ce qui le cas
aujourd'hui qui sont quand même assez
turbulentes ben ça ça complique
considérablement la tâche donc
aujourd'hui euh discours de politique
générale il a un discours de déclaration
de politique générale qui va bah c'est
alors normalement une déclaration de
politique générale dans n'importe quelle
autre démocratie c'est suivi d'un vote
de confiance c'estàdire que vous avez
vous réclamez vous demandez la confiance
de vos pères enfin de la de du pouvoir
législatif là c'est pas le cas il va pas
le faire parce que justement il a pas de
il a pas de majorité il a pas
d'obligation si il l' demandé ben il
prendra un risque énorme donc là c'est
je dirais qu'il va donner sa feuille de
route il va présenter sa feuille de
route qu'on connaît déjà on voit bien
euh euh et il va essayer de se trouver
une identité de de de d'affirmer une
espèce de de de de de d'identité surtout
par rapport au président de la
République qui est encore une fois assez
encombrant pour lui il va essayer de
trouver B un style qu'il a déjà puisquil
est assez populaire dans les sondages
les gens reconnaissent d'abord sa
jeunesse son enthousiasme sa capacité
d'écoute il a une façon de parler aussi
qui semble plaire à pas mal de gens
parce qu'il parle facilement il parle
surtout très clair oui c'est vrai qu'on
a on a forcément fait la comparaison
avec elisab born on l'imaginait moins
bien voilà dans cette situation face aux
agriculteurs queé Gabri dans un
hémicycle comme l'Assemblée nationale on
on sait que là il peut donner euh bah le
le la la la la mesure de ce qu' est
c'est-à-dire bah un jeune garçon
brillant ça c'est clair bon après euh ça
sera jamais assez euh je peux déjà vous
le dire moi ça sera jamais assez euh les
oppositions vont tirer à boulet rougge
en disant que voilà il y en a pas assez
pour le pouvoir d'achat il y en a pas
assez pour l'écologie euh parce que on a
voilà parce que parce qu'il a Ronné
aussi aux agriculteurs vera toujours
deux problèmes quand même que je vois
Gabriel Atal Macron a tout dit il y a de
semaines dans une conférence de presse
non vous l'avez évoqué mais comment il
peut se différencier qu'est-ce qu'il
peut qu'est-ce qu'il peut dire de plus
très concrètement non il peut aller
chercher sur des sujets il peut donner
beaucoup plus il peut être plus concret
ouais il peut être plus
concret il peut aussi je dirais que le
Président il y a des sujets sur lesquels
il a pas été très très présent donc
Gabriel Atal peut par exemple donner
davantage
de sur l'immigration sur la délinquance
faut pas oublier ces sujets-l ils ont
pas disparu avec la crise agricole T c
surtous ces sujets-l il peuTent
peut-être être un peu plus précis et un
peu plus convainquant que l'a été le
président de la République oui
finalement le deuxième problème que je
voyais qui était donc de prononcer ce
discours de politique générale au milieu
d'une crise agricole c'est peut-être
finalement la solution une manière de se
différencier tiens d'ailleurs je vous
lis parce que c'est en ce moment même
Emmanuel Macron en train de s'exprimer à
Stockholm il est en voyage officiel euh
il nous dit le président de la
République il ne faut pas tomber dans
l'agribashing l'agrobashing mais on ne
peut pas on ne peut plus faire comme
avant et il dit aussi on ne peut pas
tout mettre sur le dos de l'Europe
exactement alors ça c'est c'est
effectivement il y a une tendance à
faire de l'Europe un bou émissaire assez
facile euh mais néanmoins il y a quand
même un sujet hein sur le plan européen
d'abord l'Europe qui a été très
bénéfique à l'agriculture française il y
a 40 ans ça c'est clair la la politique
agricole commune a beaucoup profité à la
France aujourd'hui le plan par exemple
qui est présenté pour il y a eu un
tournant en 92 et le plan qui est
présenté aujourd'hui par Madame Van
derlyen sur le Green Deal c'est le pacte
vert ver et Ben a quand même beaucoup de
de de et suit beaucoup de critiques à
juste titre parce que c'est un plan qui
pourrait diriger l'agriculture française
notamment vers la décroissance donc ça
c'est vraiment un sujet Gabriel qui
devrait donc parler de cette crise
agricole Yve je sais que je vais vous
relâcher dans un instant parce que je
sais que vous êtes pressé mais j'ai une
dernière question Gabriel Attal il va
faire des annonces cet après-midi il
faut qu'elle soit entendue mais il faut
pas qu'elle noie l'ensemble du discours
de politique générale parce qu'il y a
tout un tas d'autres sujets comment
trouver le bon équilibre gabrielal ah
bah si le politique le discours de
politique générale il faut que euh il ne
peut pas se contenter enfin se contenter
il peut pas se consacrer qu'à
l'agriculture il va y avoir des mesures
sur l'agriculture mais on l'attend alors
sur quelques autres sujets
essentiellement sur les services publics
c'estàdire l'école et la santé sur les
la les finances publiques aussi parce
que comme vous le savez la France est
grévée par une une dette colossale de de
quelques 3000 milliards de de d'euros et
on l'attend aussi sur et bien la
sécurité la sécurité à quelques mois des
Jeux olympique en plus merci beaucoup
Yve je vous laisse remonter dans la
rédaction du Figaro et nous on vous
laisse avec ces images pour l'instant
sal les quatre colonnes ça devrait
commencer dans 5 minutes allez-y je vous
libère
merci
déplement
z
messieurur
excusez-nous merci
beaucoup bonjour monsieur bonjour
Mon 427
Mad bonjour
bonjour
ette
[Musique]
bonjourour
bonjour bonjour
BJ
bonjour
[Musique]
la séance est
ouverte je vous indique que j'ai reçu
aujourd'hui mardi 30 janvier à
14h30
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés le propre de toute société
humaine c'est de regarder en face
l'avenir qui se dessine devant elle
interroger son modèle puiser en soi les
ressources suffisantes pour avancer
corriger ce qui doit l'être construire
les bonnes solutions une société ne se
perd jamais quand elle cherche à avancer
une société ne se perd jamais qu quand
elle doute elle perd quand le doute
l'emporte sur tout le reste quand le
doute glace quand il fige quand il
conduit à douter non pas de l'avenir qui
se dessine mais à douter de soi-même de
ses forces de ses
capacités je suis
né je suis né en
1989 l'année du bicentenaire de la
révolu
une année 89 où l'on a cru que la
démocratie libérale et le progrès
universel triompher par eux-même ma
génération a vu l'inverse se produire
parce que notre génération partout dans
le monde voit son monde chambouler plus
fortement encore que tout autre avant
elle elle est en proie au doutes doute
sur l'avenir de sa planète doute sur son
identité doute ici en France sur qui
nous sommes comme peup peup et comme
nation doute sur notre modèle social sur
nos services publics sur notre
démocratie notre responsabilité celle de
chacune et chacun d'entre nous c'est de
puiser en nous la force d'identifier
tous les ressorts pour les surpasser si
nous sommes là ici réunis si nousous
engageons par-delà nos divergences et
nos désaccords c'est que nous avons un
point commun partagé par des dizaines de
millions de nos concitoyens nous voyons
davantage de raisons d'espérer que de
c'est parce que nous sommes prêts à
affronter pour avancer affronter pour
avancer mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés en m'exprimant face à vous c'est
en réalité à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je m'adresse et à travers vous
c'est à chacun de nos concitoyens que je
veux le dire nous ne sommes pas
n'importe quel pays la France n'a jamais
été n'est pas ne sera jamais une nation
qui subit ni hier ni aujourd'hui ni
demain dans les pires moments de doute
de désarroi de désunion elle a montré sa
solidité son supplément d'âme qui fait
d'elle une nation à nul autre pareil en
cette année 2024 nous commémorerons les
80 ans du débarquement moment de
libération d'une France de soutien à des
Français pour la plupart n'avait jamais
cessé de croire en elle en cette année
2024 nous rouvrirons les portes de
NotreDame de Paris alors que l'image
rétinienne des flammes reste si vive
dans l'esprit des
Français en cette année 2024 nous
accueillerons le monde un monde
bouleversé un monde divisé oui nous
accueillerons le monde à l'occasion des
Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques laance avec puissance la
France c'est un repère c'est un idéal
c'est un patrimoine témoin d'une
histoire millénaire c'est un héritage
moral celui de la patrie où sont nés les
droits de l'homme celui d'un modèle
social protecteur envié dans le monde
entier la
France la France c'est le pays de la
création que nous soutenons et qui nous
fait rayonner c'est la patrie de la
recherche à laquelle nous donnons des
moyens sans précédent c'est la nation de
l'in
qui construit le monde de demain de
2030 la France ce sont nos jeunes qui
osent et qui se LAN la France ce sont
nos famille et toutes ces mères
célibataires qui se battent qui ne
lâchent rien
jamais ce sont nos soignants nos
professeurs nos forces de l'ordre tous
nos agents publics nos militaires qui
s'engagent pour quelque chose qui les
dépasse ce sont nos artisans qui font
rayonner nos savoir-faire nos
agriculteurs nos pêcheurs qui
travaillent matin midi et soir pour nous
nourrir
ce
sont ce sont nos élus locaux et je suis
l'un des leurs depuis 10 ans qui
s'engagent et se donent corps et âmes
pour leur territoire ce sont nos
associations nos bénévoles la France
c'estes 68 millions de Français de
l'Hexagone des outrem et de l'étranger
qui n'ont pas fini de nous surprendre
dans un monde où tout
s'accélère où tout se transforme je
refuse avec eux que notre identité
puisse se diluer ou se dissoudre la
France a son rang à tenir sa voix à
faire entendre sa singularité à imposer
nous avions nous avons une fierté
française à maintenir une fierté
européenne à consolider affronter pour
avancer les difficultés économiques les
bouleversements climatiques
démographiques géopolitiques ne nous
figeront jamais ne nous conduiront
jamais à nous perdre il ne signifie pas
la fin de tout mais le passage d'un
monde à l'autre un passage difficile un
passage douloureux inquiétant à bien des
égards mais un passage que nous
réussirons j'en suis intimement
convaincu à ceux qui veulent y voir
notre disparition j'y vois notre
renaissance parce que nous avons une
identité et des valeurs à ceux qui
veulent y voir un triangle des Bermudes
j'y vois notre caporne parce que nous
savons où nous voulons aller et que nous
y
arriverons
à ceux qui veulent y voir une perte de
boussole j'y vois une détermination
parce que j'ai confiance confiance parce
que je connais le chemin que nous avons
parcouru depuis 2017 les tabous que nous
avons levés les obstacles que nous avons
franchis j'ai confiance s' vous plaît
j'ai confiance parce que je connais les
Français leur énergie leur volonté leur
créativité j'ai confiance parce que face
aux épreuves aux inquiétudes aux crises
notre pays c'est toujours
relevé l'épidémie de covid a mis à jour
bon nombre de fractures dans notre
société elle a poussé notre modèle
social dans ces retranchements mais
notre pays a tenu et nous avons protégé
nos concitoyens mieux que beaucoup
d'autres l'ont
fait le dérèglement climatique nous
frappe plus dur plus fort plus souvent
l'exceptionnel devient la norme les
catastrophes se multiplient mais notre
pays agit avec force et jamais dans son
histoire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre n'ont baissé aussi rapidement que
l'an
dernier la guerre en Ukraine a ébranlé
l'Europe elle a détruit le rêve d'une
paix éternelle sur notre continent elle
nous a rappelé durement que la
démocratie était fragile et la liberté
un idéal toujours à défendre mais notre
pays notre Europe ont montré le visage
de la détermination face à la à
l'agresseur et sa solidarité pour le
peuple
ukrainien l'attaque terroriste
monstrueuse en Israël et la guerre au
proche- Orient on on ravivit des plaiis
des mots jusque dans notre société mais
notre pays a su se dresser répondre par
le refus de la haine et par l'unité la
crise énergétique l'inflation la menace
terroriste les crises se superposent
s'enchevêtre et s'additionne elle
n'offre aucune solution miraculeuse mais
méthodiquement avec les Français nous y
répondrons bien sûr face à ces crises
pour beaucoup de Français l'avenir est
davantage une crainte qu'une promesse et
encore trop de Français ont le sentiment
de perdre le contrôle de leur propre vie
avec le président de la République avec
mon gouvernement je ne m'y résous pas je
ne m'y résoudrai
jamais pour tous c français nous allons
continuer à affronter pour avancer pas
par des belles paroles de grandes tirad
ou de beau discours mais par des actes
des actes rapides des actes concrets de
nouveaux changements dans leur vie et
sur le
terrain madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés sous l'git du
président de la République l'identité
même de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement c'est de reconquérir notre
souveraineté française et
européenne notre promesse au français et
clair oui nous voulons reprendre notre
destin en main en ouvrant une nouvelle
page de cette conquête nous pouvons nous
abuiller sur un bilan concret tangible
et solide en 2017 ma génération n'avait
connu que la désindustrialisation qui
semblait inéluctable le chômage de masse
qui s'ancrait l'Europe qui se
désunissait la transition écologique qui
rimait avec nécessité plus qu'avec
réalité au fond en 2017 la souveraineté
de la France et de l'Europe était pour
beaucoup penser pour certains même il
s'agissait d'un gros mot nous avons
assumé de parler de souveraineté et plus
encore nous avons assumé d'en faire la
matrice de notre action et nous avons
agi nous avons engagé une action résolue
pour la souveraineté économique avec
pour la première fois le retour de
l'industrie sur notre sol n'en déplaise
au
Cassandre déplais au candre plus d'usin
qui ouvr que d'usin qui ferme en France
plus d'emplois industriels qui sont
créés que d'emplois industriels qui sont
détruits en
France ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 30
ans notre taux de chômage est descendu à
un niveau jamais atteint depuis 25 ans
et pour la 5e année consécutive notre
pays le plus attractif d'Europe pour les
investissements
étrangers nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et conquérir
notre indépendance énergétique avec une
planification écologique inédite dans le
monde et une stratégie énergétique pour
une énergie plus souveraine et plus
durable nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour la souveraineté de nos
frontières avec une loi immigration et
un Pact asile immigration au niveau
européen enfin réellement protecteur de
notre
pays nous avons engagé une action
résolue elle prendra du temps pour que
chaque française chaque Français puisse
garder le contrôle de sa propre vie
qu'il ne soit jamais entravé jamais
assigné à résidence jamais résigné et
évidemment nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour la souveraineté agricole de
notre pays mesdames et messieurs les
députés je le dis ici dès le début de
cette intervention notre agriculture est
une force pas simplement parce qu'elle
nous alimente au sens propre du terme
mais parce qu'elle cont constitue un des
fondements de notre identité de nos
traditions parce que nos agriculteurs
incarnent des valeurs fondamentales et
qui lorsqu'ils sont lorsqu'elles sont
bridées fragilise l'ensemble de la
société je pense à la valeur travail à
l'effort et à la liberté
d'entreprendre notre agriculture est une
force et notre fierté aussi alors je le
dis ici solennellement il y a et il doit
y avoir une exception agricole française
je suis
lucide je suis lucide face à
l'empilement des normes face aux
décisions qui tombent d' haut et qui
parfois tombe Donon ne sait où
l'agriculture doute elle aussi et elle
attend des réponses et des solutions
nous serons au rendez-vous sans aucune
ambiguïé madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés allez un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît devant vous je
prends la parole conscient de l'ampleur
de la tâche à accomplir je veux
m'adresser à tous les Français à ceux
qui doutent et à ceux qui espèrent à
ceux qui écoutent et à ceux qui n'y
croient plus je veux m'adresser à tous c
des Français souvent de la classe
moyenne toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont souvent le sentiment de
subir à ces Français qui ont le
sentiment d'avoir tous les devoirs quand
d'autres ont tous les droits à ces
Français qui ont parfois le sentiment
que leur propre pays s'éloigne qu'ils
n'y ont plus vraiment leur place alors
qu'ils en sont le cœur battant à ces
Français de l'Entre Deux trop riches
pour bénéficier des aides mais pas assez
pour ne pas compter qui ont le sentiment
que les décisions se prennent sans eux
et qu'elles bénéficient toujours aux
même à ces Français qui ont parfois
l'impression de vivre dans une France
archipelle dont les ponts seraient sur
le point de rompre mais ces Français qui
espèrent au fond d'eux qu'on parviendra
à les réunir à ces Français qui ne
demandent pas la lune mais simplement à
pouvoir vivre de leur travail éduquer
leurs enfants se soigner et vivre en
sécurité je les entends je les comprends
et comme la majorité y uvre depuis 2017
je veux contribuer à leur répondre je le
veux avec d'autant plus de détermination
que je sais le risque pour eux de les
laisser céder à des sirènes qui ne
conduiraient qu'au chaos à la division
et à l'effondrement car je suis
lucide que pendant que nous agissons
certains guettes entretiennent les
colères et espèrent en récolter les
fruits Mesdames et Messieurs les député
le défi est immense et j'ai bien
conscience que nous ne pourrons pas le
relever seul avec mes ministres que je
remercie pour leur engagement
faille j'ai bien conscience aussi du
message très clair exprimé par les
Français en
2022 nous avons une majorité que je
salue à qui je veux dire ma confiance et
ma fidélité mais cette majorité est
relative et les Français attendent que
nous cessionions les querelles de
principes pour échanger et pour agir
ensemble depuis 2000 depuis 2022 depuis
18 mois sur bien des textes nous y
sommes parvenus et aujourd'hui je le dis
à la majorité comme au oppos nous avons
la France en partage nous avons je le
crois un devoir commun de transcender
les clivages les désaccords et les
divisions pour RER au service des
Français
évidemment nous ne serons pas d'accord
sur tout évidemment nous nous opposerons
dans cet hémicycle et ailleurs mais je
vous le dis je ne renoncerai jamais à
dialoguer ma porte sera toujours ouverte
parce qu'à travers vous mesdames et
messieurs les députés des oppositions ce
sont les voix de millions de Français
qui s'expriment même si je ne suis pas
convaincu que ces millions de Français
attendent qu'on cherche à couvrir son
interlocuteur par des cris pendant qu'il
intervient dans l'émisyle de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi cela la méthode
que je veux pour mon gouvernement
respecter les Français respecter les
oppositions respecter notre Parlement je
m'y engage j'en serai le
garant Mée a toujours été la même chaque
Français porte une vérité sur notre pays
nous devons l'écouter et y répondre
force politique organisation syndical
élus locaux français depuis ma
nomination j'ai entamé des échanges
toujours avec franchise et lucidité
alors avec vous je veux chercher à faire
raisonner les mots de nos concitoyens
répondre à leurs inquiétudes et porter
leurs espoirs alors Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés ma priorité est
claire favoriser le travail pour que
ceux qui en sont éloignés s'en
rapprochent en soutenant n fruit de le
trava pour vivre et qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de le
responsabilité mon CAP est clair c'est
celui de la souveraineté de
l'indépendance à l'échelle individuelle
nationale et européenne ma méthode est
CLA elle reste la même dire les choses
dire la vérité même quand ça fait mal
même quand ça nous conduit à remettre en
cause nos propres décisions dire la
vérité donc et agir agir vraiment agir
maintenant madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés parler au
français c'est au fond entendre quatre
appels à l'action pour le travail pour
qu'il paye mieux et toujours plus que
l'inactivité partout et pour tous pour
nos services publics pour qu'il soit
accessible et de qualité partout et pour
tous pour l'autorité le civisme le
respect des droits et devoirs partout et
pour tous pour un environnement plus
respirable partout et pour tous et je
veux l'affirmer nous n'avons pas à
renoncer aux grandes conquêtes et à la
création de droits nouveaux mesdames et
messieurs les députés pour le travail
pour nos services publics et le
rétablissement de l'autorité dans notre
société pour la transition écologique
nous partons aujourd'hui d'un bilan
solide derrière le cap fixé par le
président de la République nous avons
multiplié les actions et les réformes et
je veux rendre ici hommage à l'action
déterminante d'Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex et ellisabeth borne don le sens
de l'État et la détermination à faire
sont des
exemples
je veux rendre hommage à la majorité
toujours mobilisée pour améliorer le
quotidien des Français je veux saluer
tous les parlementaires qui ont accepté
de sortir des logiques partisanes pour
permettre l'adoption de nombreux
textes aujourd'hui les résultats sont là
depuis 2017 nous avons montré que le
chômage de mâche n'était pas une
fatalité nous avons engagé des réformes
fortes qui avaient été trop longtemps
repoussé nous avons pris les ordonnances
travail dès le début du premier
quinquena nous avons mené une réforme de
l'assurance chômage une réforme de
l'apprentissage une réforme des
retraites nous avons lancé le contrat
d'engagement jeune baisser les impôts et
les charges et engagé une réforme
majeure du lycée professionnel
aujourd'hui le chômage a baissé de 2
points 2 millions d'emplois ont été
créés notre industrie revient avec
100000 emplois industriels créés et la
réouverture de 300 usines le nombre
d'apprentis a plus que triplé ils sont
désormais plus de 850000 en France et
nous avons le cap du million en
vue
depuis 2017 nous avons agi massivement
pour nos services publics pour notre
santé avec les 19 milliards d'euros du
segégure de la santé avec une
revalorisation historique des soignants
l'augmentation du nombre de places en
études de médecine d'infirmiers d'êtes
soignants pour notre école nous avons
engagé des transformations majeures et
agit pour l'égalité des chances je pense
au dédoublement des classes ou encore à
l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants la plus forte depuis 30
ans
pour notre sécurité nous avons investi
comme jamais par le passé 10000 postes
de policiers et gendarmes ont été créés
lors du premier quinena 8500 de plus le
seront lors de celui-ci et nous avons
lancé la création de 238 brigades de
gendarmerie nouvelle la sécurité ça doit
être pour tous y compris dans la
ruralité et dans les petites
villes depuis 20177 pour la planète nous
avons préféré au grand mot les vrais
actes nous
et nous agissons plus qu'aucune majorité
avant nous avant 2017 les émissions de
gaz à effet de ser baissai d'% en
moyenne en France dans le premier
quinena elles ont baissé de 2 % en
moyenne en France l'an dernier sur les 9
mois les 9 premiers mois de l'année
seulement elles ont baissé de près de 5%
c'est le crédit de notre action sur la
transition
écologique et conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République nous avons désoris g complète
secteur par secteur territoire par
territoire la planification écologique
nous nous donnons les moyens de réussir
et nous investissons cette année 40
milliards d'euros pour la transition
écologique madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés nous avons
beaucoup fait mais il reste encore du
chemin alors avec mon gouvernement je
suis prêt je suis déterminé nous devons
répondre aux inquiétudes de la classe
moyenne et faire en sorte que ceux qui
vont travailler puissent vivre dignement
de leur travail et gagnent toujours plus
que ceux qui ne travaillent pas nous
devons répondre au défis des emplois non
pourvus car il est incompréhensible que
le chômage reste autour de 7 % alors
qu'il y a tant d'entreprises et de
filières qui cherchent à recruter
partout sur le territoire
national nous avons en France un
paradoxe nous avons un salère minimum un
SMIC nettement supérieur à celui de nos
voisins et nous en sommes fiers mais
nous avons une part de nos travailleurs
proches du SMIC beaucoup plus importante
que nos voisin c'est un problème d'abord
nous agirons résolument pour que les
banches professionnelles qui continuent
à rémunérer en dessous du SMIC remontte
ses rémunérations c'était le cas d'une
soixantaine d'entre elles l'été dernier
grâce à la mobilisation engagée alors
nous étions descendus à une trentaine à
la fin de l'année 2023 la revalorisation
du SMIC au 1er janvier dernier en a fait
redescendre une partie en dessous du
SMIC je demande de poursuivre et
amplifier la mobilisation pour des
résultats rapides et je n'exclus aucune
une mesure pour y parvenir
ensuite nous devons faire évoluer un
système qui nous a conduit je le disais
il y a un instant depuis des décennies à
concentrer nos aides nos exonérations au
niveau du SMIC aujourd'hui pour
augmenter de 100 € le revenu d'un
employé au SMIC l'employeur doit
débourser 238 € de plus quant au
salariés il perd 39 € de prime
d'activité il voit sa CSG et ses
cotisations sociales Aug de 26 % et il
rentre dans l'impôt sur le revenu en
bref autant le dire notre système fruit
de réformes successives prpée de bonnes
intentions ces dernières décennies a
placé notre monde économique dans une
situation où il n'y a quasiment plus
aucun intérêt pour quiconque à augmenter
un salarié au Smic on ne peut accepter
une France où beaucoup sont condamnés à
rester proche du SMIC toute leur
carrière progression
salariale doit toujours permettre de
récompenser l'effort et le et le mérite
alors oui j'assume de le dire il faut
désmicardiser la France dès le prochain
projet de loi de
finances en nous appuyant sur les
propositions de parlementaires de
partenaires sociaux et sur un certain
nombre de travaux d'experts qui sont
actuellement conduits nous commencerons
à réformer ce système dans le même temps
nous devons continuer à baisser les
charges qui pèsent sur la classe moyenne
après la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation de la redevance télé la
baisse de 5 milliards d'euros des
premières tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu nous tiendrons l'engagement du
président de la République d'une
nouvelle baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards
d'euros cette baisse d'impôt sera
financée et la solidarité nationale
devra s'exercer pour nos classes
moyennes valoriser le travail ce n'est
pas seulement pour les salariés nous
agirons aussi pour nos fonctionnaires
qui permettent à l'état d'avancer et
s'engage au service de l'intérêt général
en intégrant leurs mérites et leurs
efforts à leur rémunération un projet de
loi sera déposé dès le second semestre
de cette
année nous agirons pour nos indépendants
tous nos commerçants nos artisans nos
agriculteurs qui sont indépendants en
2026 nous aurons réformé l'assiette
sociale des indépendants cela veut dire
plus de droit notamment à la retraite
sans payer davantage de cotisation c'est
l'engagement de cette
majorité 2uxème objectif pour réussir je
veux déverrouiller l'accès au travail
déverrouiller notre société je veux
permettre à tous ceux qui le peuvent de
travailler avec en tête les droits et
les devoirs de chacun le droit d'être
mieux accompagné grâce à la réforme de
France travail mais aussi le devoir de
chercher un emploi dans 18 départements
nous avons lancé une expérimentation qui
conditionne le RSA à 15h d'activité pour
l'insertion je vous annonce que nous
généraliserons ce dispositif à tous les
départements de France d'ici le 1er
janvier
de plus nous devons aller plus loin dans
la réforme de l'assurance chômage une
négociation a été lancée en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors de la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle des parcours et
des reconversions et nous souhaitons
qu'elle aboutisse à un résultat
ambitieux mais la situation économique
évolue parce que nous gardons notre
objectif de plein emploi et que nous
devons inciter toujours plus à la
reprise du travail je serais extrêmement
attentif à l'évolution de la trajectoire
financière de l'assurance chômage si
cette dernière dévie je n'hésiterai pas
comme la loi le permet à demander aux
partenaires sociaux de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier sur la base
d'une nouvelle lettre de cadrage aux
ambitions très claires inciter toujours
plus à la reprise d'emploi sans aucun
tabout nous assumerons également de
combattre toutes les trappes à
inactivité d'un côté en rendant les
droits effectif nous avons été capabl de
faire le prélèvement à la source nous
serons capables de mener à bien le
chantier de la solidarité à la source
pour éviter les démarches inutiles
garantir la justice sociale pour que
chacun touche l'intégralité de ce à quoi
il a
droit combattre les trappes à inactivité
c'est permettre le droit effectif de
chacun grâce à la solidarité à la source
et je l'assume c'est aussi assumer de
réinterroger notre modèle je pense
notamment à la location de solidarité
spécifique qui prolongeindemnisation du
chômage et qui permet sans travailler de
idé des trimestres de retraite nous
avons une conviction et une cohérence
forte nous considérons que la retraite
doit être le fruit du travail et donc
nous proposerons la bascule de
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique au
RSA et la suppression de cette
allocation chercher un modèle social
plus efficace et moins coûteux ce n'est
pas un gros mot c'est un
impératif déverrouiller le travail c'est
aussi l'adapter aux nouvelles
aspirations de nos concitoyens c'est un
fait le rapport travail a changé je
mesure dans ma génération comme dans les
autres les changements de mentalité les
nouvelles attentes sur les horaires sur
la disponibilité sur l'équilibre entre
vie professionnelle et vie familiale ces
aspirations ne doivent pas être nié
elles ne doivent pas être caricaturé non
plus au risque de décevoir certains ici
personne ne demande un droit à la
paresse dans notre
payspir être regardé pour ce qu'elles
sont notre rapport au travail c'est
notre rapport au temps à l'équilibre
personnel on ne peut pas appliquer les
mêmes calque génération après génération
les attentes changent les technologies
évoluent et font apparaître de nouvelles
fractures je pense notamment à cell
entre ceux qui peuvent télétravailler et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas télétravailler
alors les conditions de travail doivent
aussi évoluer et l'État doit donner
l'exemple comme ministre des comptes
publics j'avais décidé d'expériment
d'expérimenter dans mon administration
non pas la semaine de 4 jours mais la
semaine en 4 jours sans réduction du
temps de travail à certains endroits il
y a eu peu de candidats je l'avoue à
d'autres ils sont nombreux à avoir
choisi de pouvoir arriver plus tôt le
matin partir plus tard le soir pour
travailler un jour de moins comme
premier ministre je demande à l'ensemble
de mes ministres d'expérimenter cette
solution dans leurs administrations
centrales et déconcentré
oui l'État doit donner l'exemple
s'agissant de l'organisation du travail
notamment pour toutes ces personnes qui
travaillent dur et qui se sentent
invisibles je pense notamment aux
personnes du ménage parfois forcé à
faire des heures de transport en commun
au milieu de la nuit tout ça pour éviter
qu'elle ne travaille en même temps que
les salariés et qu'elle croiseent les
agents qui sont dans les bureaux là
aussi je veux que l'État montre
l'exemple et que désormais dans l'état
les personnels d'entretien de
l'administration qui le souhait puissent
travailler aux mêmes horaires que tout
le monde c'est-à-dire aux horaires de
bureau
oui nous devons mieux prendre en compte
notre rapport au temps et nous
considerons à avancer dans le chantier
du compte épargne temp universel
véritable sac à dos social qui doit
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
travailler beaucoup plusence s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues juste un peu
de silence il un Brou continue je vous
remercie de bien vouloir d' merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre je pense
madame la Présidente qu'ils ont compris
que je ne m'arrêterai pas malgré leur
hurlement et donc je peux continuer sans
aucune
difficulté mieux prendre en compte notre
rapport au temps et nous continuerons à
avancer dans le chantier du compteépint
temp universel je l'ai dit il y a un
instant véritable sac à dos social qui
doit permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent
de travailler beaucoup plus à certains
moments de leur vie où ils le peuvent
notamment quand ils sont jeunes et n'ont
pas encore de responsabilité familiale
pour pouvoir ensuite à d'autres moments
de leur vie travailleer moins pour
développer un projet pour s'occuper de
sa famille ou d'un proche qui en a
besoin déverrouiller notre économie
c'est aussi conquérir de nouvelles
libertés refuser le principe de rente
être capable de continuer à transformer
et libérer un projet de loi en ce sens
sera examiné au printemps il permettra
notamment de déverrouiller certaines
professions comme les syndque ou encore
les ventes en ligne de médicaments par
les pharmacies mesdames et messieurs les
députés beaucoup d'entre vous me dit
s'il est un secteur qu'il faut
déverrouiller c'est bien le logement le
problème du logement est clair il tient
à la fois à l'offre et à la demande or
pourouvoir se loger acquérir son
logement c'est pourtant de français le
projet d'une vie l'assurance d'une
retraite sereine en lien avec les élus
locaux nous répondrons à cette crise du
logement en créant un choc d'offre avec
C solutions immédiates
proposé d'abord nous allons MIV les
normes revoir les DPE simplifier l'accès
à ma Prim Ren faciliter la densification
lever les contraintes sur le zonage
accélérer les procédur ensuite nous
désignerons dans de semaines 20
territoires engagés pour le logement où
nous accélérerons toutes les procédures
comme nous avons su le faire pour les
Jeux Olympiques et paralympies avec pour
objectif d'y créer 30000 nouveaux
logements d'ici 3
ans nous n'ésiterons pas à procéder
réquisition vide notamment des bâtiments
de bureau nous l'avons déjà fait et nous
continuerons à le faire nous
continuerons à soutenir le monde du
logement social nous avons agi pour lui
en maintenant le taux du livra avec 1,2
milliards d'euros pour leur rénovation
énergétique avec des plans de rachat
massif nous voulons également répondre
aux causes structurelles de la crise du
logement social le coût élevé du foncier
avec un nouveau prêt de très long terme
2 milliards d'euros distribués par la
banque des territoires et nous allons
aussi contribuer à faire évoluer le le
monde du logement social le faire
évoluer pour inciter les élus à
développer de nouveaux programmes aussi
je vous annonce que nous allons donner
au Mair la main pour la première
attribution dans les nouveaux logements
sociaux construits sur leur commune
c'était une mesure attendue par les élus
locaux nous allons aussi engager un
chantier une réflexion pour faire
évoluer le logement social pour qu'il
réponde davantage aux classes moyennes
vous le savez d'ici 2025 toutes les
communes soumises à la loi SRU doivent
posséder au moins un quart de logements
sociaux sur leur territoire nous
proposerons et nous mettrons en débat
d'ajouter pour une part les logements
intermédiaires accessibles à la classe
moyenne dans ce calcul des 25
% mesdames et messieurs les députés des
smicardisé pour promouvoir le travail
déverrouillé pour libérer la croissance
je veux aussi débureaucratiser la France
je veux alléger le fardeau des règles et
des normes qui pèsent sur ceux qui
créent nos TPE et nos PME surtous ces
Français qui travaillent sans compter et
qui créent de l'activité et de l'emploi
il a été évalué que chaque année ce sont
60 milliards d'euros que nous perdons à
cause des démarches et des complexités
de notre quotidien aussi nous engagerons
après l'été une nouvelle étape de la
réforme du droit du travail avec un
objectif clair libérer nos TPE et nos
PME simplifier considérablement leur
quotidien et leur permettre de négocier
certaines règles directement entreprise
par entreprise mais cet élan de
simplification ne doit pas se limiter au
travail partout dans notre pays les
Français me racontent combien les normes
les oppressent les Brid les empêchent de
faire et d'avancer je pense à nos
agriculteurs évidemment je pense à tous
les petits patrons je pense à nos élus
locaux qui croulent sous les règles et
les procédures
administrative à date
le nombre de mots pour dire des normes
sur l'égifrance s'élève à 44,1 million
de mots c'est pratiquement deux fois
plus qu'il y a 20 ans à tous les
échelons il faut débureaucratiser la
France nous évaluerons les normes qui
peuvent être supprimées ou simplifiées
avec les Français avec les
professionnels avec les élus nous
regarderons les démarches qui peuvent
être améliorées tous les sujets sont sur
la table mon seul objectif c'est de
libérer les Français dans leurs
initiatives c'est de les laisser vivre
et respirer supprimer des normes c'est
possible vendredi dernier j'ai annoncé
la suppression de 10 premières normes
nationales pour nos agriculteurs et
beaucoup d'autres suivront au niveau
local en Haute Garonne en quelques
réunions sur une semaine la semaine
dernière le préfet et les agriculteurs
se sont accordés sur l'abrogation de
quatre arrêtés préfectoraux cette
logique est étendu dès cette semaine à
l'ensemble des départements
français
simplifier les démarches c'est possible
et je vous annonce que dès cette année
chacun pourra enfin porter plainte en
ligne partout sur le territoire
simplifier pour éviter simplifier pour
éviter la gabgie c'est possible et je
vous annonce une nouvelle nouvelle règle
générale simple tous les organes tous
les organismes tous les comités ou
autres qui ne se sont pas réunis ces 12
derniers mois seront supprimés par règle
générale
enfin enfin dépend entiers de notre
économie demande des simplifications
encore drastique notamment pour
accélérer le retour de notre
industrie pourquoi parce que trop de
délais c'est moins de projet et donc
moins d'emploi et moins de croissance
quand un investisseur veut implanter un
projet en Europe quelque chose lui saute
aux yeux en France il faut 17 mois en
moyenne pour implanter un projet
industriel en Allemagne c'est deux fois
moins ça ne peut pas
continuer avec le projet de loi
industrie verte nous avons marqué une
première étape je vous annonce que nous
déposerons un deuxème projet de loi
industrie verte il proposera notamment
de demander à la CNDP de concentrer ses
travaux uniquement sur les projets
d'envergure nationale
Mo de gagner dans les procédures pour
les autres
projets la bureaucratie qui recule c'est
la liberté qui avance je veux libérer
les Français des contraintes qui les
freinent et sont autant de boulets pour
notre économie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
déverrouillé dmicardisé débureaucratisé
oui mais dans un seul objectif réarmer
notre pays je veux le dire
d'emblé réarmement de la France c'est la
responsabilité budgétaire nous devons
faire preuve d'une responsabilité
exemplaire dans nos finances publiques
il en va de notre souveraineté il en va
de la survie de notre modèle social il
en va de la protection des plus
fragiles de la protection des classes
moyennes qui serai les premières
victimes des coupes massives et des
Hauses drastiques auquel nous serions
contraints si nous ne tenons pas notre
trajectoire de réduction des déficits et
de notre dette et je le dis pour nous
meilleur moyen de réduire nos déficits
ça restera le travail et la croissance
pour certains la croissance est un gros
mot et pour cela on a que le mot taxer à
la bouche tout y est passé dans les
propositions parlementaires ces deux
dernières années j'étais au première
loges en tant que ministre du Budget
vous avez voulu taxer les heures
supplémentaires des ouvriers le
patrimoine des retraités et même les
successions des petits agriculteurs à
cela je le réaffirme quand on taxe tout
très vite il n'y a plus rien à taxer et
on ne taxe plus rien du tout
je vous confirme que nous poursuivrons
le même cap repasser sous les 3 % de
déficit public d'ici 2027 grâce à plus
de croissance plus d'activité à la
maîtrise de nos dépenses pas grâce à
trop d'impôts grâce à des économies de
structure aussi nous mettrons toutes nos
forces dans la bataille nous allons
poursuivre et renforcer les revues de
dépenses auquel tous les min ministère
et tous les secteurs de l'action
publique seront associés les premières
propositions d'économie pour le prochain
PLF issu de ce travail seront annoncé
dès le mois de mars et je souhaite
qu'elle donne lieu très vite à des
échanges avec la représentation
nationale madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés ce réarmement
que nous construisons avec le président
de la République il a un objectif
prioritaire assurer notre souveraineté
alors oui nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté nationale et
européenne où nos frontières doivent
être respecté la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale doit continuer à
s'intensifier il faut assumer
d'accueillir moins pour accueillir mieux
nous continuerons à déployer la border
force lancée dans les alpes maritimes
qui a déjà permis plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'interpellations à la
frontière italienne je tiendrai
l'engagement de ma prédécesseur de
réformer l'aide médicale d'État nous le
ferons avant l'été par voie
réglementaire avec une base qui est
connu le rapport evvin
stéphanini défendre notre nationale
c'est aussi donner les moyens
nécessaires à nos armées pour protéger
nos territoires et nos valeurs nos
militaires se battent au péril de leur
vie pour défendre notre pays et notre
République et dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire nous tiendrons
nos engagements vis-à-vis d'eux en de
quinen nous aurons doublé le budget du
ministère de la
défense avec vous tous avec vous toutes
je veux rendre homage au et aux hommes
de nos armées rendre hommage à ceux qui
sont tombés pour nous défendre leur
sacrifice nous oblige notre
reconnaissance est
infinie
notre souveraineté c'est aussi notre
capacité à répondre aux besoins de nos
concitoyens et donc sur ces fondements
nous allons réarmer nos services publics
ils ont toujours été une fierté ils
doivent le rester et pour certains
d'entre eux le redevenir nous allons
continuer à réarmer notre système de
santé et avec vous je veux rendre
hommage à tous les soignants de France
chacun à leur poste chacun dans leur
spécialité Ils sont les visage de
l'engagement de
l'accompagnement de l'attention et de
l'humanité
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quel est le
problème malgré le travail de nos
soignants le temps médical manque un peu
de silence nos compatriotes ne trouvent
pas suffisamment de médecins et les
délais aux urgences se rallongent cela
se traduit par la désertification de
notre pays et
la saturation de nos hôpitaux et en
particulier des urgences l'objectif est
clair plus de temps médical premier
pilier agir pour qu'il y ait plus de
médecins devant les Français les effets
de la suppression du numérus closus ne
se feront pas sentir immédiatement alors
nous devons mettre en œuvre des
solutions fortes tout de suite c'est
pourquoi comme l'a annoncé le président
de la République nous procéderons à la
régularisation des médecins étrangers
sur notre
territoire
c'est pourquoi aussi je vous l'annonce
je nommerai un émissaire chargé d'aller
chercher à l'étranger des médecins qui
voudrai venir exercer en France et nous
devons trouver les moyens de faire
revenir nos jeunes Français qui sont
partis étudier à
[Applaudissements]
l'étranger nous devons aussi nous devons
aussi c'est ce qu'a proposé le député
ner mieux reconnaître l'expertise et la
volonté de soignants qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études et qui ont une vraie
expérience une infirmière anesthésiste
qui a un bac + 5 plusieurs années de
carrière et d'expérience elle doit
pouvoir si elle le souhaite rentrer
directement au moins en 3e année de
médecine pour devenir médecin si elle le
souhaite deè pilier agir pour qu'il n'y
ait aucun territoire oublié nous avons
depuis 2017 déployé le service d'accès
aux soins le sas il permet un progrès
notable dans l'accès aux soins non
programmés je l'ai vu encore récemment à
Dijon dès cet été chaque département
devra être doté d'un service d'accès aux
soins avec des professionnels organisés
pour assurer la permanence des soins
dans les départements où il n'y aurait
toujours pas de service d'accès aux
soins et de répones satisfaisante je
suis prêt à aller plus loin en
restaurant des obligations de garde pour
les médecins libéraux en soirée ou le
weekend dans leur cabinet à l'hôpital ou
en maison de
santé 3isème pilier libérer les médecins
pour qu'ils se concentrent sur le soin
nous poursuivrons les chantiers que nous
avons engager notamment pour
l'attractivité de tous les métiers du
soin nous allons accélérer le passage de
6000 à 10000 assistants médicaux qui
permettront aux médecins de pouvoir se
conentrer consacrer davantage au
patients et moins formalités
administrativ concrètement cela
représente 2 millions et demi de
consultations supplémentaires libéré
tous les ans pour les patients ensuite
nous allons poursuivre notre action en
faveur de l'hôpital les moyens du Ségure
de la santé ne sont pas encore arrivés
partout ces lourdeurs ces lenteurs sont
insupportables cela changera rapidement
enfin il y a encore aujourd'hui trop de
rendez-vous médicaux qui ne sont pas
honorés pour les médecins il est
insupportable d'avoir chaque jour des
patients qui ont un rendez-vous et qui
ne se présentent pas pour les Français
il est insupportable de savoir que des
millions d'heures sont perdus alors
qu'ils attendent parfois des mois pour
un rendez-vous je souhaite un principe
simple qui se traduise par des mesures
claires dès cette année quand on a
rendez-vous chez le médecin et qu'on ne
vient pas sans prévenir on
paye protéger nos concitoyens c'est
aussi les accompagner à tous les âges de
la vie et à toutes les étapes de la vie
nous continuerons à agir pour l'enfance
notamment l'enfance en danger nous
continuerons à bâtir une société où
chacun peut vieillir dignement comme il
l'entend en facilitant le maintien à
domicile de ceux qui le souhaitent et en
améliorant le quotidien en épade le défi
humain et financier est immense et nous
avancerons ensemble mesdames et
messieurs les députés parler de santé
c'est trop souvent oublier la santé
mentale le mal-être les dépressions les
pensées suicidaires ont beaucoup
progressé chez nos jeunes je veux faire
de la santé mentale de notre jeunesse
une grande cause de notre action
gouvernementale avec là aussi des
mesures claires et
immédiates d'abord réformer le
dispositif mon soutien PSI il faut être
lucide ce dispositif partait d'une bonne
intention mais il n'a pas donné les
résultats escomtés il faut avoir le
courage de le reconnaître même si c'est
nous qui l'avons mis en
place je vous annonce donc que nous
allons le rénover de fond en comble nous
allons augmenter le tarif de la
consultation remboursé pour limiter au
maximum le reste à charge pour les
jeunes patients et leur famill et pour
lever tous les verrous nous permettrons
aussi aux jeunes d'avoir accès
directement au psychologu pris en charge
sans nécessairement passer par un
médecin de plus nous allons mailler
notre territoire de maison départemental
des adolescents il y en a 50 aujourd'hui
je souhaite qu'il y en ait une par
département dans notre
pays pour la santé et notamment la santé
psychologique infirmières scolaires sont
des relais essentiels auprès des élèves
elles accomplissent un travail
remarquable elles accompagnent les
jeunes avec disponibilité écoute et
soins nous devons recruter davantage
d'infirmières scolaires et mieux
reconnaître leur
engagement aussi je vous annonce et
c'est grâce à un amendement porté par
cette majorité un budget supplémentaire
dans le dernier PLF que j'ai décidé de
verser aux infirmières scolaires en mai
prochain une prime exceptionnelle de 800
€ et de revaloriser leur salaire de 200
€ net par mois à compter de cette
date je demande également au
gouvernement de travailler à des
revalorisations pour les autres
personnels sociaux et sanitaires en
milieu scolaire madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
renforcer nos pouvoirs public c'est
aussi agir pour notre école je veux ici
rendre hommage à nos
professeurs ils s'investissent tous les
jours au service de notre école de nos
élèves et donc de notre
pays j'ai souvent dit ma fierté d'être
leur ministre et aujourd'hui comme
premier ministre je n'oublie rien de ce
que nous leur devons et je serai
toujours à leur côté je l'ai dit sur le
Peron de l'hôtel de Maignon
[Applaudissements]
je l'ai dit sur le perron de l'Hôtel de
Matignon dès mes premières minutes comme
premier ministre l'école et la mer des
batailles sur l'école là aussi il faut
partir de la réalité des faits et pas
uniquement des classements
internationaux il suffit d'écouter ce
que nous disent nos français et
notamment les parents et les
grands-parents que nous disent-il que
ces dernières décennies le niveau a
baissé que si le nombre d'heures
d'absence remplacé à triplé ces derniers
mois le compte n'y est toujours pas que
nous disent les professeurs qu'ils
croient en leur métier mais qu'il est de
plus en plus difficile à exercer qu'ils
ont parfois peur d'enseigner dépend
entier de notre histoire et de notre
littérature que nous disent les jeunes
qui envisagent de devenir enseignant que
la formation initiale telle qu'elle est
organisée ne correspond pas à leurs
attentes et freine leur
vocation nous allons continuer à leur
répondre pour élever le niveau des
élèves j'avais lancé le choc des savoir
il doit maintenant se déployer le choc
des savoirs c'est assumer que tout le
monde ne progresse pas au même rythme
que tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
facilités ou les même difficultés la
décision du redoublement sera désormais
à la main de l'équipe pédagogique et les
groupes de niveau commenceront à se
mettre en place dès cette année dans nos
collèges parce qu'une école du passage
automatique où l'on glisse de classe en
classe sans vérifier si on a le niveau
pour passer dans la class supérieure
c'est une école où tout le monde stagne
où le niveau baisse nous assumons de
porter une école des savoirs de
l'exigence de l'excellence où chacun
apprend à son
rythme améliorer les savoir c'est
évidemment aussi agir sur la question
des remplacements nous évaluerons le
PACT enseignant et si de nouvelles
mesures s'imposent nous les prendrons
veiller au niveau des élèves c'est
réagir face au nouveau défis qui les
menacent les écrans sont une catastrophe
éducat et sanitaire en puissance nous
avons d'ors et déjà interdit le portable
au collège et comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République nous
travaillerons à mieux réguler l'usage
des écrans dans et en dehors de l'école
pour nos
enfants j'ajoute qu'une école des
savoirs c'est aussi une école qui permet
de se projeter dans l'avenir désormais
tous les élèves de Seconde devront faire
un stage de 2 semaines nous continuerons
à rapprocher l'école de l'entreprise des
métiers des administrations des
associ une école qui fonctionne c'est
une école où nos professeurs sont mieux
formés nous réformerons la formation
initiale des enseignants pour construire
les écoles normales du 21e siècle cette
réforme sera présenté d'ici au mois de
mars une école qui marche c'est aussi
une école où les élèves sont heureux
trop longtemps le bien-être des élèves
est resté un impensé le résultat nous le
connaissons ce sont notamment les drames
du harcèlement notre stratégie contre le
harcèlement qui a permis de briser des
tabous majeurs et très concrètes
désormais c'est l'élève harceleur qui
doit quitter l'école plus l'élève
victime qui subissait la double peine je
suis fier que nous ayons décidé de ce
changement le bien-être à l'école c'est
aussi donner toute leur place aux élèves
en situation de handicap bâtir une
société inclusive est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement cela vaut
dans tous les domaines j'y suis très
attentif nous accompagnerons nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap en
toute circonstances nous leur
simplifierons la vie nous prendrons
intégralement en charge le remboursement
des fauteuils roulants de ceux qui en
ont besoin comme nous y sommes
engagés nous agirons partout et
particulièrement à l'école depuis des
années l'État et les collectivités se
renvoie la balle sur la prise en charge
des aesh sur la pose du Midi résultat
dans beaucoup d'endroits personne ne le
finance et la conséquence c'est une
double défaite des élèves qui ne sont
pas suffisamment bien accompagnés au
moment du repas et des AES S qui ne
peuvent pas faire un temps complet pour
améliorer leur rémunération il faut
sortir de cette situation où chacun se
renvoie la balle je prends une décision
claire l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et financera désormais
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation de handicap sur le temps du
déjeuner en lieu et place des
collectivités
locales c'est un enjeu de solidarité de
dignité et de reconnaissance réarmer
l'école c'est réaffirmer nos valeurs car
je crois que la transmission du savoir
est impossible sans respect de
l'autorité sans de nos valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
la laïcité on ne négocie pas avec la
République on l'accepte on la respecte
en entier sans ma sans la moindre
exception c'est pourquoi nous déploirons
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école symbole d'égalité République
et comme l'a annoncé le président de la
République si cette expérimentation est
conclliante nous généraliserons
l'uniforme en France à la rentrée 2026
je veux le dire également je ne peux pas
me résoudre à ce que certains
professeurs craignent d'aborder certains
chapitres du programme à la moindre
entorse à notre pacte républicain il
doit y avoir des décisions fortes et des
sanctions fermes et cela doit nous
conduire à revoir l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolaire pour ne rien laisser
passer mesdames et messieurs réussir le
réarmement civique c'est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement nous
devons faire respecter l'autorité
partout dans les classes dans les
familles dans les rues ce respect
s'apprend à l'école je le disais mais ce
respect passe aussi par les familles les
violences de juillet dernier ont
profondément marqué notre pays parmi les
émetiers des très jeunes très jeunes
parfois qui semblaient avoir déjà coupé
les ponts avec notre société qui ne
respectent plus leurs parents pour qui
la violence semble un moyen comme un
autre de tromper l'ennui je ne me
résoudrai pas à ce qu'on a préfère
attendre avant de donner une lourde
peine alors que bien souvent c'est très
tôt qu'il aurait fallu agir nous devons
disposer de sanctions adaptées pour les
mineurs de moins de 16 ans pour eux on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui prononcer de
peines de travaux d'intérêt général je
vous annonce que nous créerons des
travaux d'intérêt éducatif qui seront
leur équivalents et seront donnés plus
facilement que des peines d'intérêt
général cela fera partie cela fera
partie de la révision de l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolaires que j'évoqué il y a un instant
dès le plus jeune âge il faut en revenir
à un principe clair tu casses tu répares
tu sies tu nettoies tu défies l'autorité
on t'apprend à la
respecter
nous responsabiliserons aussi davantage
les parents dans le cadre du projet de
loi sur la justice des mineurs nous
soutiendrons la mise en place de travaux
d'intérêt général pour les parents de
jeunes délinquants qui se sont
totalement et volontairement soustraits
à leurs obligations et responsabilités
parentales mais je le dis il est tort de
question d'accabler certaines familles
quand on est une mère seule de plusieurs
enfants dans un quartier on peut-être
totalement dépassé par les événements et
on n'est pas toujours responsable de la
dérive de ses enfants pour elle au
contraire cette dérive est un échec et
une douleur terrible nous devons les
aider et je ne me résous pas à ce que
nous ayons une situation où nous ayons
des familles dépassées par les
événements avec des enfants qui ne
respectent pas nos règles et qui sont
violents d'un côté et 50000 places
d'internat disponibles de l'autre nous y
répondrons désormais quand un jeune sera
sur la mauvaise pente plutôt que de les
laisser plonger dans la délinquence nous
proposerons aux parents de le placer en
internat en y facilitant l'accès y
compris financier nous allons le couper
de ces mauvaises fréquentations nous
allons lui offrir un cadre un
enseignement une
chance le réarmement civique c'est bien
entendu le respect de la loi nos
concitoyens attendent de nous que nous
agissions encore et toujours contre les
violences contre les trafi contre les
cambriolages contre l'insécurité du
quotidien et la délinquence il demande
de l'ordre dans nos rues tout n'est pas
une question de moyens il faut les
mettre au service d'une stratégie plus
offensive encore comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous allons
doubler la présence policière dans les
rues d'ici à 2030 nous allons mener des
actions coordonnées de tous les services
de l'État forces de l'ordre éducation
services sociaux dans certains quartiers
c'est le sens des forces d'action
républicaines nous les déploierons dès
la fin du mois de février dans trois
premiers territoires à maobbeuge à
Valence et à Besançon contre
l'insécurité nous nous sommes fixés deux
priorités la lutte contre les
stupéfiants et la lutte contre la
délinquence du quotidien en particulier
les
cambriolages nous allons encore monter
d'un cran dans notre combat contre la
drogue en mettant en œuvre un nouveau
plan de lutte contre les stupéfiants
notre stratégie de harcèlement et de
pilonnage contre les dealers porte ses
fruit nous avons réussi à faire
disparaître un/art des points de Deal
alors nous allons poursuivre avec 10
opérations place net par semaine nous
devons aussi taper les dealers au
porte-monnaie et leur couper les vivres
c'est pourquoi nous allons désormais
geler les avoirs des trafiquants de og
qui sont
identifié notre réarmement civique passe
par une justice plus rapide et plus
efficace ensemble nous allons envoyer un
message clair l'impunité c'est fini nous
avons décidé de moyens exceptionnel pour
notre justice ils seront en rendez-vous
pour accélérer les délais nous allons
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice avec plus de magistrats plus de
greffi avec une organisation plus
respectueuse de nos concitoyens et une
nouveauté désormais les français ne
seront plus convoqués sur des créneaux
pouvant courir sur une demi-journée
entière mais sur un créneau horaire bien
défini c'est aussi par ce type de mesure
et de preuve de respect que l'on renoue
le lien entre la justice et les
justiciables
enfin notre réarmement civique c'est
renforcer l'unité républicaine de notre
jeunesse c'est permettre à tous les
jeunes de France de faire nation c'est
le rôle même du service national
universel je lance les travaux en vue de
sa généralisation à la rentrée
mesdames et messieurs de les députés
parler de nos services publics c'est
aussi parler de nos territoires chacun
n'a pas les mêmes défis les mêmes
attentes les mêmes besoins j'évoquerai
demain longuement devant le Sénat la
stratégie sur les territoire je veux
d'ors et déjà ici puisque vous êtes
aussi élu de circonscription et pour un
bon un bon nombre d'entre élus locaux
comme moi vous dire quelles sont nos
attentes mon gouvernement sera toujours
à l'écoute des territoires et des des
élus locaux toutes les solutions se
construiront avec eux je peux vous
assurer aussi que nous cherchons
toujours des solutions adaptées aux
réalités du terrain en ayant recours à
la différenciation à l'adaptation des
normes nous continuerons à avancer c'est
le sens de la mission confiée à Eric
vert qui nous remettra ses propositions
dans les prochains mois nous chercherons
ensemble un chemin pour une autonomie de
la Corse dans la République comme s est
engagé le président de la République
alors que je parle de différenciation de
territoirees j'ai une pensée pour les
territoires d'outreemè où elle s'impose
tout particulièrement il réarmé nos
services publics il est peut-être plus
crucial plus vital encore qu'ailleurs
les outremers sont un atout déterminant
pour notre pays il y a dans chaque
territoire d'outremè l'enthousiasme de
notre jeunesse la détermination à
réussir l'avenir mais nos outremèes
concentrent aussi tous les défis contre
la vie chère pour l'emploi pour la
sécurité pour la santé l'école la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale et la
transition écologique chacune de nos
politiques publiques doit tenir compte
des spécificités outremè j'y tiens et
pour faire face aux enjeux exceptionnels
auxquels son territoire est confronté
nous déposerons une loi sur Mayotte je
veux ici avoir un mot particulier pour
la Nouvelle-Calédonie je souhaite que le
processus politique en cours aboutisse
j'y veillerai et vous examinerez dans
quelques semaines un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
ensemble je vous propose d'accélérer
encore notre transition écologique
le dérèglement climatique ce ne sont pas
seulement quelques degrés de plus ce
sont des vies détruites par les
intempéries ce sont des exploitations
agricoles menacé et avec elle toute
notre capacité à nous nourrir ce sont
des maisons et des immeubles menacés par
la montée des eaux fissurés par les
mouvements des sols face à ces constats
certains voudraient une écologie de la
brutalité pour eux l'écologie doit être
punitive douloureuse passer par la
désignation de Bou émissaire et par la
décroissance la décroissance je le redis
ici c'est la fin de notre modèle social
c'est la pauvreté de masse jamais je ne
l'accepterai je crois au contraire qu'on
ne fera pas l'écologie contre le peuple
je crois au contraire qu'il faut
entendre les inquiétudes des Français de
tous les Français il faut entendre les
agriculteurs qui travaillent et qui
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir et leur
métier il faut entendre les élus locaux
qui veulent développer leurs communes il
faut entendre les millions de Français
des villes moyennes des petites communes
et de la ruralité pour qui la voiture ég
etté l'écologie s le peuple c'est PAV le
chemin aux crises social et au
renoncement au contraire nous allons
continuer à bâtir ensemble une écologie
populaire une écologie à la française
avec les Français pour les Français
c'est le sens de la planification
écologique qui protègera la biodiversité
et permettra une baisse radicale de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre une
baisse de 55 % d'ici
une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie où chacun agit à la hauteur de
ses moyens c'est pourquoi l'État sera
exemplaire c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons d'aider les entreprises à
participer activement à l'effort je suis
fier que les 50 sites industriels les
plus émetteurs 50 sites qui
représentaient à eux-mêmes 10 % de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France se soient tous engagés à réduire
leurs émissions de près de moitié d'ici
2030 et je vous annonce je vous annonce
que nous lancerons une initiative
similaire contre la pollution plastique
pour les 50 sites qui mettent le plus
d'emballage plastique sur le
marché une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie des solutions le président de
la République s'était engagé à lancer
une offre de véhicule électrique pour
moins de 100 € par mois cet engagement
est tenu et le succès est déjà au
rendez-vous le président de la
République s'est engagé à développer les
r métropolitains à investir massivement
dans le FERR cet engagement lui aussi
nous le tiendrons une écologie populaire
c'est une écologie de la croissance et
de l'emploi le retour de l'industrie les
investissements en faveur de la
décarbonation grâce à France 2030 les
métiers de la rénovation thermique ou le
secteur de l'économie circulaire oui la
transition écologique regorge
d'opportunités de secteurs en croissance
de filières nouvelles oui nous ferons
rimer climat avec
croissance
une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie qui se construit au plus près
des réalités des Français et des
territoires des concentrations des
concertations sont en cours partout en
France au côté des élus locaux nous
donnerons à chacun les moyens de le
faire et je souhaite que le financement
de leurs plans locaux de transition
écologique soit établie partout d'ici
l'été une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie qui protège et assure notre
souveraineté grâce à la sobriété aux
énergies renouvelables au nucléaaires
nous allons assurer notre indépendance
énergétique je veux le dire sans
ambiguïté là aussi il faut être clair le
nucléaire est une fierté
française le nucléaire c'est un atout
majeur pour notre pays j'assume d'être à
la tête d'un gouvernement pro énergie
nucléaire avec une majorité pro énergie
nucléaire qui me
soutient nous allons continuer à la
montée en puissance de notre parc
nucléaire investir massivement dans les
programmes cette année le Pr de
flamandville sera opérationnel c'est
aussi grâce au nucléairirees que nous
pouvons garantir les meilleurs prix aux
Français nous protégerons mieux les
consommateurs et régulerons les prix
d'électricité afin qu'il se rapproche
des coûts de production et nous
continuerons à développer les énergies
renouvelables de la même manière que
nous développerons le nucléaire dans
notre pays
enfin mesdames et messieurs les députés
bâtir une écologie populaire c'est
répondre aux aspirations de notre
jeunesse réussir la transition
écologique et le défi de notre
génération notre jeunesse veut s'engager
participer aider elle le fait déjà
beaucoup d'ailleurs elle se demande
parfois comment être utile pour la
planète c'est pourquoi nous lancerons un
service civique écologique qui
rassemblera d'ici à la fin du quinena
50000 jeunes prêts à s'engager
concrètement pour le
climat j'ajoute j'ajoute que si nous
devons réduire nos émissions et protéger
notre biodiversité nous devons aussi
nous adapter au dérèglements climatiques
nous adapter c'est nous préparer c'est
veiller à ce que chacun même les plus
fragiles soit prêt face au ravage du
dérèglement climatique nous présenterons
dès ce trimestre un nouveau plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique il
présentera des solutions adaptées à
chaque territoire notamment dans les
outr-mers enfin je vous annonce que nous
ferons évoluer le régime de catastrophe
naturelle pour le moderniser et éviter
que certains assureurs n'abandonnent les
territoires les plus à risque
enfin je l'ai déjà évoqué et j'y reviens
nous devons mener notre réarmement
agricole produire et protéger pour notre
souveraineté voilà mon approche depuis
2017 nous avons engagé ce combat de la
souveraineté et du revenu c'est le sens
des plans de filière des différentes
lois igalim du varen de l'eau nous avons
débloqué 250 millions d'euros pour
trouver des alternative au
phytosanitaire c'est un effort inédit
sur l'Union européenne nous avons
toujours été moteur sur la réciprocité
et les closuses miroir et nous les
ferons respecter
produire produire produire
oui ça vous dérange produire produire
c'est d'abord donner du temps à nos
agriculteurs pour passer plus de temps
dans leurs champs moins de temps devant
leurs écrans produire c'est être
souverain je souhaite que cet objectif
de souveraineté alimentaire soit
désormais clairement inscrit dans la loi
protéger aussi protéger face aux crises
climatiqu et sanitaire le gouvernement
l'a toujours fait lors du gel des
sécheresses de la grippe avière nous
avons adopté un budget de l'assurance
récolte sans précédent avec un budget
historique nous continuerons à le faire
protéger face à la concurrence déloyale
c'est le combat pour la réciprocité et
pour les mesures miroires que je vais
continuer à mener avec détermination ce
combat il doit se mener en Europe comme
nous l'avons fait sur les médicaments
vétérinaires mais nous devons aller plus
loin changer de logique j'assume de dire
que tout ne sera pas réglé en quelques
semaines j'assume de dire que les
chantiers sont complexes et que pour
certains il faudra y travailler encore
j'assume aussi d'apporter des réponses
rapides partout là où c'est possible
très concrètement sur Galim dès la
semaine dernière 100 inspecteurs de la
DGCCRF supplémentaire ont commencé leurs
contrôle sur le terrain qui seront deux
fois plus nombreux qu'auparavant c'est
une vague de contrôle sans précédent sur
la trésorerie des exploitants nous
avançons dès à présent dès février 50 %
des remboursements ticp seront versés
aux exploitants soit 733 € par exemple
pour une exploitation utilisant 7000 l
de de GNR dès la semaine prochaine 5
février précisément un guichet pour la
prise en charge des frais vétérinaires
concernant la MHE sera ouvert il
permettra de verser les premières
indemnisations dès la fin du mois de
février le taux de prise en charge des
frais vétérinaires a été révalué à 90 %.
d'ici le 15 mars toutes les aides PAC
seront versées sur les compes bancairees
des exploitants et nous travaillerons
avec les
régions
et nous travaillerons avec les régions
pour que les aides à l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs puissent être versé
dans les prochaines semaines pour
certains cela fait plus d'un ans qu'ils
attendent et la semaine dernière le fond
d'urgence Bretagne a été doublé sur la
simplification j'ai parlé du travail
tout à l'heure des 10 premières normes
du travail au niveau local nous allons
poursuivre et nous irons plus loin
encore et tout ce que nous pouvons le
faire faire dès maintenant nous le
ferons d'ors et déjà je peux vous dire
que nous avons avancé ces derniers jours
dans la discussion dans l'échange avec
les agriculteurs et leurs représentants
sur une série de sujets sur l'élevage
nous avons mis en œuvre un dispositif
fiscal qui leur permet qui doit leur
permettre de faire face à l'inflation
notamment sur les prix de leur bêes nous
le renforcerons pour protéger toujours
davantage nos éleveurs sur Galim là
c'est très clair j'ai déjà parlé des
amendes et des contrôles mais je peux
vous dire que toutes les AM les amendes
qui seront infligées à l'industrie et à
la grande distribution seront réutilisé
pour soutenir financièrement nos
agriculteurs
sur la
viticulture sur la viticulture oui nos
viticulteurs souffrent mais notre
filière viticole est notre fierté elle
fait rayonner la France et donc je vous
annonce que nous allons déveloquer dans
les prochains jours des moyens nouveaux
avec un fond d'urgence avant la fin de
la semaine pour soutenir nos
viticulteurs particulièrement en
Occitanie sur les contrôle je lance
aujourd'hui un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité des produits
l'objectif est clair garantir une
concurrence équitable notamment pour que
les normes qu'on applique aux
agriculteurs soi aussi respecté par les
marchandises étrangères au niveau
européen nos trois priorités immédiates
sont claires les jchers les importations
ukrainiennes notamment de volaille et le
mercosour ces sujets seront portés sont
portés très fortement par le
gouvernement et le président lui-même
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
engagé une coalition de 22 pays sur la
question desjà chers et nous sommes
proches d'aboutir à une nouvelle
prolongation de la dérogation nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire nous prendrons
toutes les mesures pour éviter toute
surtrposition d'où qu'elles viennent je
le sais nous ne sommes pas au bout du
chemin il y aura de nouvelles conquêtes
dans les jours qui viennent je pense
notamment aux jeunes agriculteurs à la
transmission des exploitations mais nous
agissons vite fort avec détermination et
respect pour nos
agriculteurs madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés réarmé
la France s continué à conquérir de
nouveaux droits le président de la
République a fait de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes la grande cause de
ces quinquenas
elle sera au cœur des engagements de mon
gouvernement c'est le sens de la réforme
du congé parental annoncé par le
président de la République aujourd'hui
le congé parental ne laisse pas assez de
revenus aux familles bien souvent il est
inégalement réparti dans le couple
éloigne durablement les femmes de
l'emploi alors comme toutes les
inégalités nous devons la combattre
aussi le congé parental sera transformé
en congé de naissance de 6 mois mieux
rémunéré que les parents pourront se
répartir entre eux conquérir de nouveaux
droits c'est reconnaître et défendre
sans relâche le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps nous inscrirons
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse au sein de notre texte
fondamental de notre
Constitution conquérir de nouveaux
droits enfin c'est être au côté de nos
concitoyens jusqu'au bout de la vie la
fin de vie est sans doute l'une des
questions les plus intimes et les plus
délicates qui soit c'est se pencher sur
son histoire c'est repenser aux
souffrances endurées par certains c'est
s'interroger sur soi-même sur ce que
l'on voudrait face à l'insupportable et
à l'irréversible face à l'irréparable on
ne peut légiférer sur la fin de vie
qu'avec une grande prudence grande
retenue et un grand respect aujourd'hui
nos compatriotes clairement nous
appellent à revoir notre droit c'est une
demande des familles c'est une demande
des malades c'est un appel grave auquel
nous devons répondre nous y répondrons
nous renforcerons considérablement les
unités de soins palliatifs dans notre
pays avec une unité par département
avant l'été nous examinerons un projet
de loi sur l'aide active à mourir dans
notre pays ce débat animera notre
société je le sais je souhaite qu'il
puisse se tenir dans une volonté
d'équilibre et dans le respect des
convictions de chacun madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés je viens de tracer les grandes
orientations que suivra mon gouvernement
en suivant ce chemin je propose au
français d'avoir pleinement le contrôle
sur sur leur vie je souhaite que la
France retrouve pleinement la maîtrise
de son destin qu'elle soit pleinement
souveraine une souveraineté industrielle
technologique et
numérique créatrice d'innovation et
d'emploi une souveraineté énergétique
qui nous protègera des crises protègera
l'environnement et garantira des prix
plus bas au français une souveraineté
agricole qui nous permettra de nourrir
notre pays avec les meilleurs produits
d'assurer l'avenir de notre agriculture
et dans les tous prochains jours j'aurai
des annonces supplémentaires à faire sur
le sujet une souveraineté culturelle o
notre notre création notre patrimoine
sont soutenus où notre exception
culturelle est protégée où la culture
est enfin accessible à tous mesdames et
messieurs les députés je parle de
souveraineté nationale mais c'est aussi
par l'Europe que nous parviendrons à la
consolider depuis 2017 et le discours de
la Sorbonne du président de la
République l'Europe a changé elle a
surmonté les crises pris ses
responsabilités c'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons pu avoir des vaccins face
à l'épidémie grâce à l'Europe que nous
avons bénéficié du plan de relance
massif c'est grâce à l'Europe que nous
soutenons l'Ukraine depuis le premier
jour face à l'agression russe grâce à
l'Europe que nous avons imposé des
normes au géant du numérique grâce à
l'Europe que nous avons instauré un
impôt minimal sur les grandes sociétés
multinationales pour lutter contre
l'optimisation fiscale grâce à l'Europe
que nous contrôlerons mieux nos
frontières grâce au Pact asile
immigration un Pact que je en une phrase
nous contrôlerons enfin qui peut entrer
dans l'espace Schengen et qui ne le peut
pas grâce à l'Europe aussi que nous
investissons massivement dans certains
secteur stratégique et pour notre
industrie je le dis ceux qui prôent la
fin de l'application des traités sont
les partisans d'un frexit déguisé qui
affaiblirait la
France
moins d'Europe moins d'Europe c'est
moins de puissance pour la France je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple et il fera mal à
certains ici le brexit ces partisans
promettaient des jours heureux à
l'économie britannique et au peuple
anglais la semaine dernière à cause du
brexit les derniers au fourneaux de
Grande-Bretagne ont fermé on ne produit
plus d'acier au Royaume-Uni nous en
France au contraire notamment grâce aux
invest l'UR l'industrie
revient qui était qui étai les premiers
partisans en France du brexit qui a
baptisé dans les villes qu'il dirige des
rues ru du brexit qui s'est affiché
ouvertement avec le leader du camp du
brexit c'est le rassemblement
national
l'Europe l'Europe éternel Bou émissaire
de ceux qui fautent de pouvoir diriger
un pays veulent détruire tout un
continent pas un Français ne pense que
nous pouvons nous passer d'Europe pas un
français non plus ne pense que l'Europe
a su pleinement trouver la juste place
dans sa vie ils ont raison tout n'est
pas parfait il reste des chantiers à
mener mais les faits sont là avec
l'Europe notre puissance est
démultipliée et ces dernières années
nous avons commencé à la
changer
et je le dis solennellement à l'heure où
il est minuit Mo- une dans le siècle
face au impérialismes les masques
devront tomber on peut vouloir changer
l'Europe pour l'intérêt du pays et nous
le faisons mais on ne peut pas vouloir
sortir de l'Europe sauf à avoir d'autres
intérêts sauf à servir un autre pays une
autre
puissance
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés voilà les grands
principes qui guideront mon action celle
de mon gouvernement pour la France et
pour les français pour notre France qui
n'a jamais perdu son ambition de
grandeur pour ces Français qui n'ont
jamais manqué à leur devoir ces axes que
je vous ai présenté ils sont une réponse
aux enjeux de la nation probablement pas
la seule mais le reflet de l'ambition
que nous portons avec le président de la
République il correspondent aussi au
rêve qu'une génération avait appris à ne
plus porter trouver un emploi stable
acheter un logement fonder une famille
faire des sacrifices mais acceptables
s'ils servent à l'ascension de leurs
enfants aimer les paysages une culture
commune une société libre et tenue dans
une époque si difficile il n'y a pas de
réponse simple mais il y a des espoirs
tranquilles à raviver j'assumerai
toujours toujours de débattre avec vous
je respecterai toujours vos opinions vos
propositions je ne rejetterai jamais la
critique tant qu'elle est constructive
ces mots ces mots je les adresse à vous
je les adresse aussi aux Français je
sais leurs attentes je sais qu'ils ne me
pardonneront rien les temps sont
troublés les doutes sont nombreux mais
l'espoir est
là la France est puissante parce que ce
qui nous réunit est toujours plus fort
parce que la France notre pays notre
nation notre terre demeureront notre
fierté parce que oui être français en
2020 2 oui c'est une fierté notre
société est plus ouverte plus audacieuse
plus pionnière que l'image que nous nous
renvoyons parfois à nous-mêmes être
français en 2024 c'est vivre dans un
pays où l'histoire s'écrit être français
en 2024 c'est vivre dans un pays qui n'a
pas renoncé au progrès social à protéger
les droits de tous et surtout de toutes
et en conquérir de nouveau être français
en 2024 c'est vivre dans un pays dont
l'honneur est de se battre pour la
stabilité du monde pour la justice et
pour la paix être français en 2024 c'est
dans un pays qu' il y a 10 ans seulement
se déchirit encore sur le mariage pour
tous pouvoir être Premier ministre en
assumant ouvertement son
homosexualité de tout cela je vois la
preuve que notre pays bouge la preuve
que les mentalités évoluent la preuve
que nous n'avons aucune raison de céder
à la fatalité alors je n'ai qu'une chose
à dire à nos concitoyens quelle que soit
leur couleur de peau leur origine leur
adresse leur croyance la France est
votre
et en France tout est possible madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés oui nous sommes fiers d'être
français et avec vous je veux faire
briller cette fierté française je viens
de vous présenter le cap de mon
gouvernement le cap pris sous l'autorité
du Président de la République pour
reprendre pleinement notre destin en
main et restaurer notre souveraineté et
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts prêts à
voir la vérité en face prêt à écouter
prêt à entendre la voix de tous les
Français prêt à agir prêt à uvrer sans
relâche fidèle à notre devise République
prêt à garantir la liberté à vrer pour
plus d'égalité à toujours choisir la
fraternité parce que madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés nous ne sommes pas n'importe
quel pays nous ne serons jamais une
puissance moyenne qui se résignerait au
déclin avec fatalité nous ne sommes pas
condamnés à subir mais déterminés à agir
déterminés à prendre notre destin en
main déterminé madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés parce
que nous sommes la France et que rien ne
résiste au peuple
français
1h 20 de discours Gabriel Atal vient de
conclure son discours de politique
générale devant les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est partisans
sont évidemment debout les autres
restent assis n'applaudissent pas et
siffl probablement pour certains
carlmeus bonjour bonjour Tib rédacteur
en chef au Figaro Magazine euh on va
débriefer tout ça et on va se poser
cette question du du jour c'est la
question du jour du Figaro d'ailleurs
êtes-vous convaincu par le discours de
de Gabriel Atal eu par quoi voulez-vous
commencer tiens si vous deviez retenir
un point Carle de ce qui vient d'être
dit par Gabriel Atal voilà un point sur
sur une disoui c'est ça qui va ressortir
là dans le journal tout à l'heure sur le
site du Figaro.fr de quoi va-t-on parler
de l'agriculture un peu oui mais ça
c'est l'actualité immédiate donc c'est
sûr non moi je je vais vous aimez bien
mon esprit de contradiction je je vais
retenir deux deux termes oui classe
moyenne et travail oui alors tiens
travail j'ai l'impression on va
commencer là-dessus car si vous voulez
bien c'était créneau d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 ça fait à peu près 5 ans qu'on
en a plus entendu parler et là alors non
mais quasiment c'est V dis qu'ils ont
fait beaucoup de choses sur voilà mais
alors là on a parlé beaucoup du travail
quoi c'est le retour du du macronisme
original je pense que il faudra étudier
attentivement le contenu du discours
mais je pense que c'est le mot qui
revient le plus souvent en tout cas dans
la toute première dans la première
partie je dire les trois premiers quart
d'heure parce qu'après au bout de à
15h50 il commence à parler éducation
puis transition écologique mais le mot
clé c'était c'était travail et et dans
ce cas-là effectivement c'est je
m'adresse au classe moyenne parce qu'en
gros c'est dire il faut que le travail
paye il faut que moi chôur si je reviens
au travail et ben je je puisse vivre de
mon travail il faut remettre voilà les
gens au travail donc je pense que
c'était c'était ça le Light motif et en
cela d'ailleurs vous vous évoquez la
référence à 2017 ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que tout le début du
discours il s'est inscrit dans cette
continuité oui euh de 2017 comme si
voilà il il englobait tout ce qui avait
été fait avant lui euh pour pour le le
évidemment le prendre à son compte
l'intéger défendre hein d'une certaine
manière et mê temp c'est comment dans la
continuité c'est ça c'est le changement
dans la continuité voilà parce qu'on
voit bien le changement il sait que il a
une non pas une durée de vie courte mais
que s'il veut convaincre il faut qu'il
aille vite et qu'il faut change les
choses très rapidement et c'est ce qui
est intervenu assez souvent dans son
discours aussi c'est ce côté il faut
aller vite on va changer rapidement il
faut qu'il y ait des résultats concrets
vous avez toujours les les images pour
ceux qui nous regardent à la télé de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur Matth mod
hein c'est ça puisque chaque groupe va
désormais prendre la parole on écoutera
tout à l'heure les les oppositions pour
l'instant on débrief ce qui s'est dit
euh ce qu'a dit Gabriel Atal alors
quatre piliers hein le travail on va
évidemment le développer les services
publics l'autorité et l'environnement
voilà ce que ce qu'a voulu mettre en
avant Gabriel Atal avec un mot partout
et pour tous voilà ce qu'il disait on
reste sur le
travail avec une vision bon c'était
aussi la panage de d'Emmanuel Macron
mais assez moderne du travail hein par
exemple la semaine des 4 jours essayer
de penser autrement le travail voyez
avec le le mettre en avant le temps
qu'on a et cetera au fond et c'est ça
c'est très intéressant ce que que vous
évoquiez ça parce que il parle pas de la
semaine de 4 jours il dit la semaine en
4 jours oui subtile non je ouioui mais
pour le coup c'est une conversation
qu'on a eu quand il était ministre des
comptes publics et
euh bon je vais vous parler pas de mois
mais je lui disais mais au fond la
semaine de 4 jours euh ça nous ramène à
Jospin au moment de la discussion sur
les 35hur il y avait cette volonté aussi
de réduire ce temps de travail à fond
mais c'est encore aggé ce droit à
lapparisse d'ailleurs dans dont il a dit
qu'il n'existait pas et en fait c'est
lui qui m'a dit non on va faire on fait
pas la semaine de 4 jours c'estàd qu'on
ne réduit pas le temps de travail mais
on demande sur la même durée de temps de
travail de faire ce temps de travail en
4 jours plutôt qu'en 5
et c'est là où en réalité il s'adresse à
cette classe moyenne qui perd des heures
et des heures dans les transport et au
fond c'est quelque chose on peut le dire
moi je j'habite pas très loin de Paris
je viens à vélo électrique ça ne me
concerne pas les ambouage sur Twitter
est assez virulent sur la question non
mais exigeant exig Raon exigeant mais
voilà gabrielal sa préoccupation ce sont
tous ces gens obligé d'habiter en grande
couronne en dehors des métropoles obligé
de prendre les transports en commun qui
souvent sont en retard ou sont annulés
ou ne marche pas et qui perdent 1 he à
1h30 quand c'est pas 2h tous les jours
voir parfois 3h quand ils ont 1h3 de
trajet et ces gens-là en fait il s'est
rendu compte parce qu'il a fait
l'expérimentation dans son ministère
d'ailleurs il a eu l'honnêteté de
reconnaître que il y avait pas eu
beaucoup de volontaires dans certains
cas mais que en revanche si quand il y
avait eu des volontaires là ils étaient
très contents h parce que ces gens-là
ils préfèrent venir plus tôt partir plus
tard pendant 4 jours mais avoir une
journée à eux où ils ne seront plus dans
la galère des transports et où peut-être
ils vont pouvoir faire leurs courses en
dehors du samedi qui est le jour où tout
le monde fait les courses donc vous vous
retrouver encore dans des bouchons dans
des machins et du coup avoir un samedi
où ils sont pour leurs loisirs c'est une
vraie révolution il a demandé à tous les
ministère de l'expérimenter exactement
parce que il veut d'abord le faire dans
l'administration pour pouvoir dire nous
ce qu'il a dit on on donne l'exemple
mais après à chaque entreprise il veut
pas l'imposer voyez c'est c'est
l'inverse de de Jospin et des 35h c'est
pas je l'impose d'en haut je sais que
c'est bien non il l'a d'ailleurs dit il
y a des gens qui peuvent pas
télétravailler et il y a des gens qui
ont des des boulots au contraire qui sur
lequel ça s'y prête il y a des gens
comme vous et moi ça nous dérange pas de
travailler 5 jours parce queon a pas de
contraintte bon préfér préféreriez
travailler de jours vous me l'avez dit
Antine mais ça c'est pas travailler du
tout même non mais vous voyez ce que je
veux dire tous ceux qui sont dans cette
situation là et c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce que euh il y a cet
aspect quand même assez nouveau de
s'adresser à des Français à qui
généralement on ne s'adresse pas tous
ces gens qui sont dans le RER qui
habitent en PR en 2uxè couronne qui sont
loin voilà comme je disais qui ont été
mis hors des métropoles ben oui mais
tous ces gens-là c'est qui c'est c'est
cette France de gilets jaunes c'est
cette France alors pas pas des
agriculteurs parce que pour le coup
c'est 7 jours par
mais voilà une frche de la population à
qui il dit voilà je vous écoute je
comprends vos votre problématique on va
essayer de changer tout ça vous
réagissez avez-vous été convaincu par la
déclaration de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal oui non on verra dans un
instant les réponses des internautes du
Figaro la question du travail avec je
pense ce mot qui va ressortir
desmicardiser la France ça c'est
intéressant parce que les discours
s'appuient aussi sur des mots forts des
petites trouvailles et ça h oui voilà
c'est le côté euh pour déverrouiller
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire bah oui
dmicardiser donc on va voir
effectivement si la postérité retient
retient ça mais euh euh ou l'idée c'est
l'idée c'est quoi c'est de dire on
travaille le chômage baisse mais pour
l'instant les gens gagnent pas assez et
on reste c'est ça he c'est surtout dans
dans son discours c'était de dire le
problème c'est quand vous voulez
augmenter un smicar les charges sociales
augmentent les charges qui pèse sur le
patron augmente aussi et finalement
c'est pas intéressant de l'augmenter ni
pour les uns ni pour les autres et donc
il y a des gens qui passent leur vie au
SMIC et donc l'idée voilà c'est
d'essayer de de décloisonner tout ça
vous savez euh et une fois de plus là
quand je vous entends j'entends Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 hein mais complètement
mais ils veulent retrouver
les l'ADN de 2017 et d'ailleurs c'est
pas innocent si on entend parler aussi
d'une loi Macron 2 alors là Gabriel Atal
ne l'a pas dit de cette manière- làà
aussi explicite mais on sait qu'il y a
des des propositions qui commencent à
tourner pour déverrouiller de nouveau
des secteurs aller sur des rentes
pourquoi ils font ça parce que euh ils
veulent arriver à ce qu'Emmanuel Macron
appelle le plein emploi par ce qui
généralement selon les économistes c'est
5 % de la population active chômage
chômage 5 % le problème c'est que là on
en est plutôt à 7 et ça tendance à
remonter vers 8 et on sait que cette
année sera pas très bonne et donc ce
qu'ils veulent faire c'est pour éviter
et de se retrouver dans le piège de
François Hollande sur la verersion de la
courbe du chômage où tout le temps on le
ramenait à ça chaque mois que le chômage
aait augmenter on bah c'est un échec et
tout ça donc pour éviter ça il faut
remettre des Français au travail ceux
qui sont le plus éloignés du du travail
et donc déverrouiller déverrouiller tout
ce qui peut être déverrouillé et qui
empêche les les entreprises d'embaucher
cette cette image en direct toujours de
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est Jean-Paul
mat qui prend la parole chaque groupe à
l'Assemblée va s'exprimer après le
discours de politique général de Gabriel
Atal on y vient dans un instant avec les
ténors de de l'opposition mais pour
l'instant on débriff ce qu'il s'est dit
avec Carl mus sur le travail je note
aussi la grande question du Mérite hein
ça c'est aussi ça aussi été mis en avant
par par Gabriel
hatal les services publics l'école
l'école bon on l'attendait un peuin ça
fait un moment qu'il en parle pas de
grande nouveauté il a surtout rappelé ce
qu'il avait déjà dit et qu'il ferait oui
la grande priorité
du gouvernement ça n'arrive que à 15h50
d'un discours qui commence à 15h5 donc
bon mais comme vous le dites et puis
Emmanuel Macron avait dévoilé beaucoup
de des choses dans sa conférence de
presse voilà ce qui était intéressant
c'est pour ceux qui ont suivi en direct
c'est de voir la la tête d'Amélie a
casterra très concentré sur tout ce qui
devait être dit et le réalisateur de
l'Assemblée nationale qui a dû se
régaler d'aller trouver le visage de
d'AV caster non l'aspect peut-être
enfin nouveau je parle là peut-être sous
votre contrôle c'est le côté révision
des sanctions avec quelques formules tu
casses tu répare c'est-à-dire que
maintenant voilà ça c'est vous AZ RA je
rappelle les quatre piliers hein c'est
lui qui a commencé son discours comme
cela en parlant du travail des services
publics et de l'autorité ça c'était sur
la question de l'autorité des principes
simples tu casses tu répares alors c'est
vrai qu'on était ici ensemble on discuta
et tout de suite ça nous interpellit et
au fond on on a là peut-être un début de
ce que peut être l'atalisme si vous me
permettez on a souvent dit Gabriel Atal
mais il pense quoi c'est quoi tout ça
bon et ben là on voit à la fois sur le
travail à la fois là sur l'autorité
l'école c'est c'est au fond revenir à
des basiques à des choses simples à des
choses qu'il entend quand il
parle bon sens un peu bon sens c'est
toujours un peu évanaisent mais j'allais
dire le bon sens St rien mais bon
Gabriel Atal on le sait c'est quelqu'un
de un Parisien PE che donc mais voilà il
y a ce côté les Français me disent je
vois des choses mais au fond pourquoi
moi politique je ne pourrait pas les
porter ou en tout cas utiliser des mots
simples et puis surtout arrêter avec le
il faut pas faire de vagu bon il y a un
carreau cassé quelqu'un a cassé un truc
c'est pas grave on passe l'éponge non là
tu casses tu répares il faut qu'il ait
les sanctions dès la première bêtises on
va voir s'ils y arrivent hein parce que
souvent on a entendu comme ça des
ministres des premier ministres nous le
dire je je il até annoncé des travaux
d'intérêt éducatif voilà l'une des
annonces de de Gabriel hatal dernier
grand point alors la santé les services
publics on accélère Carl mais là aussi
des Annonces notamment sur les médecins
les médecins étrangers qui seront
régularisé et des médecins qui on va
aller chercher à l'étranger aussi la
question de l'environnement là aussi
c'est le grand euh thème du voilà assez
tard hein lui qui est ministre Premier
ministre et Premier ministre en char
l'environnement à un moment j'ai failli
me dire ils vont pas en parler ils vont
encore l'oublier mais non non non là ils
en ont parlé avec des phrases fortes
quand même euh réaffirmant le le
nucléaire la France est une nation
nucléaire bon j'assume être à la tête
d'un gouvernement et d'une majorité pro
nucléaire voilà B ça c'est c'est bien
d'être dit parce que si vous voulez par
rapport à 2017 là il y a presque une
petite rupture alors Emmanuel Macron
n'aime pas qu'on le rappelle enfin le
début du du premier quinquena c'était
plutôt on va fermer des des centrales et
on va passer au tout énergie
renouvelable oui dans la continuité des
de François Holland voilà il y a eu un
changement de pied heureusement et
maintenant on est parti à fond sur le
nucléaire donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
avez-vous été convaincu par la
déclaration de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal vous dites oui vous dites
NON Carl mus nous donne son avis dans
dans un instant il a parlé de
l'administration aussi
déburaucratiser la France bon ça c'est
tout le monde le dit tout le monde mais
mais ça ne se fait jamais bah et surtout
ces fameuses agences qui ne se sont pas
réunies depuis un an qu'il faudra fermer
le nom intéressant ça oui mais ça tous
les en presque tous les premier
ministres disent on va fermer oui oui
mais à limite pourquoi pas tant mieux
hein c'est ça fait permet de faire des
économies il en faudra parce que il y a
quelque chose quand même qui qui devrait
aussi être retenu c'est la confirmation
de la baisse des charges sur les classes
moyennes ces fameux 2 milliards promis
par Emmanuel Macron repris par Gabriel
Atal sur le thème on va le faire mais
attention il a dit il faut que ça soit
financé et il a parlé de solidarité
nationale ça tre intéressant de savoir
dans son exactement vous posez la bonne
question qui va devoir faire preuve de
solidarité envers les classe moyenne
allez encore quelques points évoquer on
l'a pas on l'a pas évoqué mais tiens on
le voit le ministre de l'Agriculture
marquen sont des images enregistrées je
vous remontre les images en direct ce
sont celle-ci avec Jean-Paul matthille
qui s'exprime toujours au pupitre il est
pas vraiment au perchoir le perchoir
c'est audessus he ah non le Percho
c'estudessus la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ou ou non le PER
voilà il s'exprime devant lesp ut à la
suite de de Gabriel s êre méchant on va
dire il s'exprime devant les députés qui
sont
restés beaucoup sont sortis beaucoup sal
des qu colonnes pour faire des réactions
mais là il en a quand même pas mal non
la majorité là j'ai été méchant la
majorité resté on voit que le
rassemblement national est parti partie
aussi il reviendront très vite lorsque
Marine Le Pen prendra la parole c'est à
nen pas douter autre point donc
extrêmement important on l'attendait
l'agriculture alors il a été assez malin
parce qu'il en a parlé tout de
suite mais sans pour y revenir à la fin
c'est plutôt intelligent parce que c'est
une priorité mais ça ne peut pas être ma
priorité unique sur les 3 ans à venir
donc j'en parle à la fin promis je voilà
plôt malin comme manère de fa c'est un
discours de politique générale donc il
peut pas axer tout sur l'agriculture et
en même temps il est obligé d'y répondre
et il fallait pas noyer ses propositions
au milieu de tout le reste compliquéé et
sachant que ce ne sont pas les
propositions tel qu'il pourrait les
formuler aujourd'hui qui vont dénouer la
la situation c'est plutôt ce qui va se
passer demain ce que va dire Marc fenau
ce que pourrait dire le président de la
République à Bruxelles bon donc on voit
bien que il savait que les les blocages
les barrages n'allaient pas être levés
après son discours donc d'ailleurs il
l'a répété à plusieurs reprises il sera
amené à prendre de nouvelles décisions
ils l'ont précisé et donc voilà mais il
fallait quand même montrer que la
préoccupation de l'actualité n'était pas
absente Boris Valot du Parti socialiste
qui prend la
parole à l'Assemblée nationale oui les
les agriculteurs bon pas sûr qu'ils
arrêtent de leur blocage après ce qu'ils
ont entendu cet après-midi oui mais
c'était même sûr qu'ils arrêteraient pas
après le discours de politique générale
hein de toute façon c'est pas ça ça veut
dire parce que depuis une semaine pardon
Carl j'entends souvent on revient vers
vous très rapidement et là on vous fait
des annonces là dans les 48 heur mais
quand est-ce que ça se passe
concrètement réellement avec des
annonces qui peuvent demain dans la
semaine Gabriel Atal en a vu hier il va
continuer Marc fen va continuer à les
discussions euh il voilà ils savent bien
les agriculteurs sont montés ils vont
pas redescendre tout de suite voilà les
blocages les barrages sont là il faut
qu'ils prennent la mesure de tout ça et
c'est pas ce discours de politique
générale qui allait faire lever les
barrages point intéressant en fin de
discours Carl sur l'Europe alors
l'Europe c'est souvent l'international
c'est souvent la priorité en tout cas le
le job du président de la République qui
aime bien se l'approprier là il en a
parlé je vous ai posé la question mais
pourquoi il en parle vous avez un mot
très juste une campagne qui arrive oui
la campagne des européennes le 9 juin et
on sait que Gabriel Atal va être l'un
des des fer de lance de la macronie
contre le rassemblement national et
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas raté le seul parti
qu'il a cité pour le contrer dans son
discours de politique générale c'est à
ce moment-là de son discours sur
l'Europe et c'est le rassemblement
national au moment où il a parlé du
brexit ou il a DITC il accuse les
partisans et je cite d'un frexit déguisé
qui affaibliré la la voilà en prenant
l'exemple de l'Angleterre qui n'a plus
d'Assyrie et de voilà et donc c'est si
vous voulez c'est intéressant parce
lance la campagne des européennes oui
mais Elisabeth bornne n'avait pas du
tout pris à sa charge la campagne
générale des
législative peut-être que Emmanuel
Macron l'avait payé là il a compris que
le chef de la majorité devait porter la
campagne de son camp oui en fait il
avait il y avait deux objectifs chaque
discours de politique générale
correspond à au moment auquel il est
prononcé à l'objectif qu'il a si on
compare ce discours avec celui par exle
d'édard Philippe ou Jean Castex c'est
pas la même chose parce que eu avaient
une majorité absolue ellisabeth borne
elle avait une feuille de route qui
était essayer de trouver un compromis
avec l'ELR et pour élagir sa majorité et
dans mon souvenir son discours de
politique générale d'ailleurs elle elle
citait souvent des exemples ou des des
propositions des uns et des autres
montrant qu'elle les avait repris bien
le résultat ça ça n'a rien bougé oui
parce que il faut le rappeler si vous
avez raison de le préciser Carl
ellisabeth borne avait fait son discours
de politique générale après les
législatives même si elle était premier
ministre avant les Législatives elle a
il fallait mener la campagne puis
ensuite son son discours mais il fallait
qu'elle éargisse la majorité Gabriel
Atal il a une une double mission d'abord
il doit rassurer et et consolider sa
majorité ce discours il s'adressait
beaucoup aussi euh à ses députés au
députés de François Baayou du MoDem et
au députés horizon d'Édouard Philippe
pour leur dire voilà il y a des mesures
là-dedans voilà notre feuille de route
ça ça doit vous plaire et d'ailleurs on
a vu l'ensemble des députés se lever à
plusieurs reprises l'applaudir donc
mission réussie de ce point de vue-là sa
deuxème mission c'est de mener la
campagne des des législatives euh il y a
trois personnes quand on est dans la
majorité qui qui sont en charge de la
campagne des européennes qui sont en
charge des européennes il y a le tête la
tête de liste bon elle est toujours pas
désigné non àis peut-être euh son
peut-être ça se terminera comme ça mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus le nom qui est
cité euh vous savez j'ai retouvé euh il
y a 5 ans oui pour la désignation de la
tête de liste ils avaient programmé un
meeting le 26 mars la tête de liste elle
a été désignée le 20 mars 6 jours avant
un meeting organisé et les élections ét
au moiseau qui avait été choisi un
meeting je à d'ailleurs ou bon bon là on
est en début février euh c'est en juin
voyez il y a pas vraiment d'urgence
sachant que les deux autres qui mènent
la campagne c'est évidemment le
président de la République et la mission
on en arrive à la deuxième mission de
Gabriel Atal c'est réduire l'écart avec
le RN et d'être un des chefs de fil de
cette campagne et donc là la fin de son
discours c'était ça c'était de de
prendre à parti le RN de de montrer
qu'il y a un face- à faceace entre lui
et le RN évidemment pour installer débat
le seul parti seul nom de par parti
qu'il a cité c'est le rassemblement
national même si dans son discours ce à
quiil a semblé le plus répondre était
plutôt ceux de la gauche qui le sifflait
qui le tit assez largement tout au long
de cette heure 20 de discours parce
qu'on sait bien que la stratégie de de
LFI d'une partie de la nube c'est
d'essayer de faire dégoupiller à la
tribune en criant en vociférant coupant
le discours bien avant de répondre Carl
à cette question avez-vous été convaincu
par la Déclaration de Politique général
de Gabriel Atal dernier point le style
le style Atal c'est vrai que c'est
souvent un peu ennuyeux c'est longs
discours de politique générale moi je me
suis pas ennuyé là voilà si je dois
donner un avis personnel donc vous vous
avez parce que vous aussi vous donnez
votre avis vous avez été convaincu moi
convaincu ou oui c'est toujours un peu
difficile mais il a été assez offensif
il ne s'est pas laissé démonter il a
répondu même directement au députés
qu'il sifflait il la présidente de
l'Assemblée à un moment a dit s'il vous
plaît laissez parler Gabriel a dit ils
peuvent crier de toute façon je continue
exactement non j'ai trouvé alors est-ce
que c'est parce que je savais qu'on
faisait l'émission j'étais plus attentif
peut-être si ça joue he on était là mais
il y a pas il y avait pas de temps mort
voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire vous
le dites parfois dans un discours de
politique générale il y a des moments où
on se dit bon
allez là il est en train de cocher les
cases de tout do dire voà parce que
évidemment si ça se trouve il a oublié
bon il a pas parlé peut-être admettons
il a pas parlé des transports bon alors
voilà il toujours pas de ministre
d'ailleurs il y a toujours pas de
ministre il a parlé du logement mais il
y a pas plus de ministre non plus bon
mais le le le risque du il y a deux
risques dans un discours de politique
générale 1 c'est de faire ce catalogue
oui où je m'adresse à tout le monde j'ai
un mot pour tout le monde et alors là
vous en avez pour 2 heures et c'est
ennuyeux et tout et il y a un 2uxè r
C'est c'est georgees Pompidou qui
l'avait vu quand Jacques chabandmas
avait fait son discours de politique
générale appelant à une nouvelle société
et Pompidou avait dit rien n'est pire
que de faire rêver les Français oui mais
alors Pidou lui paraît-il avait
complètement manqué son discours de
politique générale alors ah ça j'étais
trop jeune je sais pas je suis non mais
voyez comme quoi même pas né car c'est
vrai en plus non je vous demande pas
votre âge mais on en revient à ce qu'on
disait sur gabriatal voilà le concret
ouis des mesures concrètes des choses
que les Français peuvent comprendre
intégrer et surtout où ils se disent ça
me concerne ah oui le nombre de médecins
ça me concerne le la semaine en 4 jours
tiens euh pourquoi pas il faudrait que
ça soit parce que il essaie de
déclencher les choses que les gens se
disent ça me concerne est-ce que
euh ça va me toucher et et et et qu'en
cascade tout ça arrive à bouger donc on
est vraiment là dans dans dans le plus
pur produit de de gabriatal c'est-à-dire
que vraiment le concret faire changer
les choses le plus possible rapidement
et là on va voir s'il va y arriver parce
que l'environnement de Gabriel etal n'a
pas changé l'environn du gouvernement le
gouvernement a changé mais son
environnement il a toujours une majorité
relative il l'a dit il a d'ailleurs
lancé un appel en disant je discuterai
avec vous nous allons je serai toujours
là pour négocier mais la réité on va
vite la voir elle va lui revenir presque
peut-être comme un boomerang c'est avec
la motion de censure est-ce qu'il arrive
à passer cette première ce premier
obstacle motion de censure oui déposé
par la nuups vous avez vraiment une
inquiétude non norm
devra pas la voter mais le rassemblé
nationale pourrait la voter qu'ils ont
il s'interdisent rien la question c'est
est-ce que le les LR ne sont pas
suffisamment énervés par ce qui s'est
passé avec le le Conseil constitutionnel
qui a censuré après le gouvern peut
toujours s'en laver les mains c'est pas
de notre faute c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel oui mais enfin bon ils
ont fait passer des messages Emmanuel
Macron a saisi lui-même le Conseil
constitutionnel sur le
thème nettoyez-moi tout ça enlevez-moi
tout ce dont je ne veux pas et je crois
pas que ce a annoncé Gabriel Atal sur
laame Swan nature a rassuré les LR il a
dit oui je vais tenir l'engagement
d'éizabeth borne sur laame mais il a dit
ça ne sera pas une loi et il a dit ça
sera sur la base du rapport Evin
stéphanini qui en gros disait bon il y a
pas de gros problème je vous rappelle
que nous sommes en direct ici avec ces
images de l'Assemblée nationale Boris
valallot du Parti socialiste prend la
parole à la suite de Gabriel hatal on
écoutera dans un instant les ténors de
de l'opposition Carl il est l'heure de
de répondre avez-vous été convaincu par
la déclaration de politique générale de
Gabriel hatal oui ou non alors c'est
quoi le résultat bah non j'atts
j'attends j'attends bon allez je vous ai
trouvé plutôt convaincu vous m'avez dit
qu'il y avait pas eu de temps mort en
tout cas sur le style avezv été
convaincu par Carlus et bien écoutez non
61,58 % des internautes du Figaro ne
sont pas convaincus par la déclaration
de politique générale de Gabriel Atal
bon c'est pas non plus catastrophique8
61 je trouve que ça reflète bien euh
l'équilibre qu'il y a dans le pays
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien que Gabriel
Atal son arrivée à Matignon à à plus à
certaines personnes mais qu'il est quand
même sous surveillance et là on voit
bien 61 % c'est effectivement
majoritairement des gens qui n'ont pas
été convaincus mais il en a quand même
voilà 38 % il a un socle sur lequel il
peut s'appuyer et sous surveillance ça
veut dire que ce socle il peut l'élargir
c'est à lui de d'y arriver et bien tiens
justement Carl il a fini avec ça il a
plelé au débat Gabriel je vous écouterai
toujours je suis prêt à discuter et
surtout il a terminé en France tout est
possible ce qui renvoie quand même un
slogan bah oui ou un slogan de Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2007 ensemble tout devient
possible il y a des clin d'œil comme ça
en politique merci beaucoup Carl mus
merci de nous avoir aidé à répondre à
cette question du jour avez-vous été
convaincu par la déclaration de
politique générale de Gabriel hatal bon
qu'attendre maintenant de des
oppositions
pareil c'est un discours attendu là oui
c'est convenu presque évidemment il
n'aura pas réussi à convaincre il sera
contraint il n'a pas de majorité non
vraiment l'enjeu c'est de savoir si
cette motion de censure est-ce que une
partie des du groupe lot vous savez ce
petit groupe centriste
charnière qu'ils ont ils avaient réussi
pour au moins la la loi immigration à à
les faire basculer dans la majorité
est-ce qu'il vote ou pas ce cette motion
de censure et est-ce queil il y a des LR
qui se laisse tenter pour voter avec
laanubs on va voir on vous laisse avec
Laurent
marcangéi groupe horizon he c'est ça oui
le finalement dans la majorité la
majorité complet donc pour l'instant il
y a eu mat du MoDem Valo dans
l'opposition du PS marcangéi d'horizon
on attend donc les prise de parole de
rassemblement national de la France
insoumise et DLR notamment qui sont les
principaux groupes d'opposition merci
beaucoup Carle vous libère et puis nous
on vous vous laisse avec les députés à
l'Assemblée ne seront utiles au pays que
si nous fixons un cap clair ce cap c'est
celui d'une France plus juste et plus
prospère pour le plus grand nombre c'est
ce qui a guidé l'action de chaque
premier ministre depuis 2017 et je veux
ici saluer l'action d'eddouard Philippe
Jean Castex et ellisabeth
borne Monsieur le Premier Ministre les
espoirs et attentes de nos concitoyens
sont immenses la tâche pour ne pas les
décevoir est d'autant plus
ardu comme avec votre prédécesseur vous
trouverez les députés du groupe horizon
et apparenté à vos côtés pour travailler
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
partenaire sérieux partenaire loyal mais
partenaire exigeant c'est ainsi que nous
concevons d'accompagner votre action
gouvernementale nous devrons apporter
des réponses rapides mais pérenes sur
plusieurs sujets prioritaire que je me
permettrai de décliner dans la suite de
mes propos surtout ces solutions ne
porteront leur fruit que si elles sont
de bon sens nous croyons fermement que
l'immense majorité des Français souhaite
en réalité de la Justice de la
simplicité et de
l'efficacité depuis quelques jours les
revendications agricoles nous rappellent
à quel point de nombreux Français se
sentent abandonnés dans l'époque qui est
la nôtre ils s'y sentent d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux parfois prisonniers
il désespèent de la qualité de nos
débats publics et ne manque pas de nous
le faire savoir aussi je demande à
chacune et à chacun de sortir de ces
certitudes en regardant la France telle
qu'elle est et non pas tel qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit l'actualité
récente nous démontre que la
surtransposition de normes est une bombe
à retardement pour les secteurs qui la
subissent les injonctions
contradictoires le dénigrement du
travail les règles imposées en dépit du
bon bon sens font le malheur de notre
pays et en particulier de notre
agriculture si nos sols et nos
savoir-faire sont une grande et belle
puissance agricole ne les prenons pas
pour acquis il nous faut à tout prix
éviter que l'agriculture française
connaisse un déclin similaire à celui de
la sidérurgie au siècle dernier nous
saluons donc les mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement elles vont dans la bonne
direction je dis cela sans renier rien
de notre engagement pro-européen nous
voulons bien sûr une Europe qui
s'affirme davantage sur la scène
mondiale une Europe au service de ses
cito
mais aussi une Europe qui ne crée pas de
contraint
un accès au service public en luttant
pour contre les déserts médicaux en
désenclavant les territoires par une
offre de mobilité adaptée et en assurant
ordre et sécurité pour chacun la
mobilité c'est de pouvoir changer de
lieu d'habitation et de ne pas subir une
forme d'assignation à résidence or la
crise du logement est là et elle
n'épargne personne elle concerne d'abord
l'accès à la propriété avec des
acheteurs potentiels qui font face à une
hausse des taux d'intérêts et dans le
même temps une baisse des crédits
accordés par les banques initialement
créé pour répondre à ce besoin le
logement social ne tient plus sa
promesse républicaine c'est donc une
double peine pour la majorité de nos
concitoyens qui sont exclus des
logements sociaux tout en étant
confrontés à des prix sur le marché
libre bien au-delà de leur capacité en
un mot la crise du logement nous oblige
à une réponse rapide globale et de long
terme faire preuve de bon sens c'est
aussi investir pour l'avenir pour notre
jeunesse en poursuivant nos efforts au
service de l'éducation nos professeurs
sont aujourd'hui mieux rémunéré et nous
sommes rentrés dans une nouvelle ère
face au harcèlement scolaire celle de la
tolérance zéro mais beaucoup restent à
faire en particulier sur le plan du
respect de l'autorité de cette
institution et du corps enseignant je
sais Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
attachement à ce ministère qui fut le
vôtre là encore vous pourrez compter sur
nous cette capacité à voir loin pour nos
enfants se traduit aussi par la prise en
compte de l'urgence écologique dans
l'ensemble de nos politiques publiques
le cycle des événements climatiques
extrême s'accélère et trouble laquiétude
des habitants de notre pays au côté du
ministre Christophe Béchu nous prenons
une écologie pragmatique fondé sur le
réalisme et toujours de bon sens en
matière climatique comme ailleurs nos
arbitrages devront prendre en compte le
sentiment d'étau dans lequel se s pris
une grande partie de nos concitoyens
nous devons être attentif aux
conséquences qu'uront les hausses
inéluctables des factures énergétiques
et environnementale avenir les prochains
textes que nous serons amenés à voter
devons prendre cette réalité en compte
et permettre à la France de tenir son
objectif de neutralité carbone à horizon
2050 au-delà de la protection de la
planète et de la biodiversité je veux
rappeler notre engagement pour la
protection des Français en matière
militaire de justice et de sécurité
trois lois de programmation historique
ont été votées par le Parlement en un an
elle dote notre pays d'une trajectoire
claire concernant le fléchage des
dépenses dans des champs régaliens
stratégiques sur plusieurs années
modernisation de nos armées plus de
recrutement dans la justice plus de
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain c'était
là des attentes de longue date du peuple
français nous veillerons également à la
poursuite de notre politique fiscale et
à la mise en œuvre dès 2025 comme vous
l'avez annoncé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de la baisse de 2 milliards
d'euros d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes afin que le travail paye pour
paraphraser Jacques Chirac la feuille de
paix ne doit pas être l'ennemi de
l'emploi de là seulement naîtra la
compétitivité l'innovation et donc la
prospérité les députés du groupe horizon
et apparenté resteront toutefois
vigilants sur le fait que chaque dépense
soit financée afin de mettre un terme à
la croissance de la dette publique et
ainsi préserver notre souveraineté
budgétaire et
financière sujet d'intérêt pour notre
groupe la réforme de notre système de
santé doit se poursuivre personne sur
ces bancs ne peut se satisfaire qu'une
grande partie de nos concitoyens soit
privés d'une offre de soins accessibles
dans un délai raisonnable le groupe
horizon et apparenté l'a déjà affirmé
c'est aux acteurs locaux d'organiser
l'offre de soins en fonction des besoins
de chaque territoire si la baisse de la
natalité nous inquiète à juste titre il
faut aussi se préoccuper du
vieillissement de notre population autre
grand enjeu de notre siècle la
proportion des plus de 50 ans est amenée
à doubler d'ici 50 ans ce n'est rien de
moins que la soutenabilité de notre
système de santé qui est en jeu pour
cette raison nous ne pourrons pas faire
l'impasse sur une loi dédiée au grand
âgees l'année 2024 sera enfin et c'est
suffisamment peu courant pour s attarder
une année de révision constitutionn
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
ne faut modifier la Constitution clé de
voûte de notre République qu'avec une
main tremblante certains changements
apparaissent pourtant nécessaire compte
tenu de l'évolution de notre société la
consécration d'interruption volontaire
de grossesse comme droit garanti pour
toutes les femmes tout d'abord l'avenir
de la nouvelle calédoné ensuite et plus
personnel le statut d'autonomie de la
Corse que vous avez évoqué lors de votre
discours monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Premier ministre vous
l'aurez compris le groupe horizon
apparenté souhaite que notre pays
retrouve du bon sens notre programme de
travail est chargé pour peu de temps
utile notre programme est clairire
soyons efficac parlons de fond trouvons
le consensus faisons disparaître ce
sentiment de mépris source de notre
affaiblissement démocratique vous pouvez
compter sur nous notre groupe loyal mais
exigeant sera à vos côtés pour faire
réussir la France je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
président
la parole est à madame la Présidente
châelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous venez il y a quelques instants de
proclamer votre discours de politique
générale vous avez posé les priorités de
votre gouvernement avec l'emphase qui
vous caractérise là et tout votre talent
donner l'impression du mouvement alors
que tout reste figé d'ù ventrreementra
de l'action de l'action de l'action
saturer l'espace médiatique de
déplacement de mise en scène de petites
et de grandes annonces espérant que cela
nous fasse oublier l'état de la France
les services public qui s'effondre les
Français qui s'appauvrissent le climat
qui se détériore votre rôle se réduit
donc à faire office d'écran de fumée
mais les actes ont des conséquences
après cette année au pouvoir cette année
agir au sein de la majorité et dans les
gouvernements successifs d'Emmanuel
Macron permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de vous juger non sur vos
paroles mais sur votre politique
commençons par votre bilan face au péril
climatique sous l'effet de l'activité
humaine le climat sambal si rien ne
change la terre se réchauffera de 3
degrés d'ici à 200 et loin d'agir les
États se complaisent dans un statut qu
qui nous mène à la catastrophe la France
ne fait évidemment pas exception le le
10 mai 2023 le Conseil d'État exhortait
votre gouvernement à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour garantir la baisse de
40 % des émission de gaz à effet de ser
d'ici 2030 inscrite dans la loi et vous
que faites-vous vous supprimez les
nouveaux objectifs climat l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie appelle à
renoncer dès maintenant à tout nouveau
projets pétrolier ou gaziier dans le
monde et vous vous refusez de stopper h
nouveaux forages en Gironde la la monde
est entrée dans l' des catastrophes
climatiques le Nord Pascalis subit les
inondations la Réunion le cyclone Béal
la France entière les vagues de chaleur
et vous vous soutenez des projets
autoroutiers anachroniques tel la 69 la
6e extinction de masse sera bientôt une
réalité dans notre pays et vous vous
consacrez 0,14 % du budget de l'État à
la biodiversité et détricoter le code de
l'environnement la ressource en eau
pourrait diminuer de 40 % d'ici à 2050
et vous vous refusez les obj objectif de
réduction du prévénement de l'eau pour
l'industrie vous avez volontairement
capitulé face au réchauffement
climatique pourtant les conditions
vitales de l'existence ne se négocient
pas c'est pourquoi les écologistes sont
au côté de celles et ceux qui luttent
pour notre survie qui démentantellent
les projets climaticines et qui
désarmment les multinationales les
écologistes continueront à défendre des
politiques environnementale ambitieuse
la loi de programmation pour la
rénovation thermique le droit d'accès à
la nature ou encore la sortie des
énergies fossiles Monsieur le Premier
Ministre votre politique est finalement
très cohérente vous défendez ceux qui
s'acapar la terre tout comme vous
encouragez ceux qui s'acaparent les
richesses d'ailleurs bien souvent ce
sont les mêmes voici donc les
conséquences très concrètes de votre
politique un enfant sur 5 vit dans la
pauvreté un français sur qu ne mange pas
à sa fin un Français sur 10 à renoncer à
se soigner de Français sur 10 n'arrivent
pas à payer leur facture à temps et vu
vos annonce ils vont être nombreux à se
serrer encore davantage la ceinture
pourtant pour trop de nos concitoyens la
vie se rétrécit pas de vacan pas de
petit plaisir seulement travail et
facture et vous avez volontairement
capitulé face aux inégalités car soyons
honnête vous n'avez jamais cherché à les
combattre vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
persuadé et je vous cite la France
souffre davantage d'inégalité de destin
que d'inégalité de revenus oui
combattent les inégalit unité de destin
c'est donner à chacun les moyens de
s'émanciper de s'épanouir grâce à
l'éducation la culture le sport c'est de
combattre pied à pied le séparatisme des
riches c'est de donner à l'enseignement
public les moyens financiers et humains
de mener à bien sa mission offrir à tous
les enfants de France l'opportunité
d'apprendre d'aguiser leur esprit
critique et de grandir tout simplement
mais qui peut croire un instant qu'on
peut combattre les inégalités de destin
en laissant croître les inégalités de
revenus les opportunités ne sont pas les
mêmes pour les 10 % des Français les
plus pauvres qui qui disposent pour tout
patrimoine de quelques milliers d'euros
sur un livréa et pour les 10 Français
les plus riches qui détiennent en
moyenne un patrimoine de 1,1 million
d'euros disposer d'un patrimoine élevé
ce n'est pas seulement une protection
financière c'est le droit à l'erreur
c'est le droit de prendre son temps le
temps d'hésiter de se construire de se
découvrir nous proposons donc l'évidence
non pas de tout taxer mais de reprendre
au profiteurs de remettre les super
profits au pot commun et d'instaurer un
ISF climatique l'argent magique n'existe
pas le ruissellement spontané non plus
il est de votre responsabilité de
garantir la juste répartition des
richesses pour gagner contre les
inégalités il faut mener une bataille
féroce contre ses plus grands
adversaires la caparement et le
surprofit là encore forcez de constater
que vous avez volontairement capitulé
vous parlez d'autorité de sanctions
contre les jeunes contre les chômeurs
contre les précaires globalement contre
les Français mais par contre vous
manquez de courage quand il faut s'en
prendre au cupides aux multinationales
dont les marges ont bandit durant la
crise car ell spéculent sur la guerre
elle spécule sur les impacts des
catastrophes climatiques pour faire face
aux actionnaires qui font des plusvalues
sur la difficulté des Français et
considère les énergies fossiles
mortifères comme une machine à cach
pendant que la planète étouffe total
réalise plus de 19 milliards d'euros de
bénéfice pendant que les agriculteurs se
démènent la fortune des trois frères qui
possèdeent Lactalis représente 43
milliards pendant que les Naves
fréatiques s'achèchent les actionnaires
de NESTLE se sont partagés 19 milliards
de dividendes le système marche sur la
tête pour preuve en un an les prix de
l'alimentation dans les magasins on
augmenté de 8 % pendant que les prix
d'achat aux agriculteurs a baissé de 9
%. les seuls gagnant les seuls gagnants
ce sont les industries agroalimentaires
dont les marches sont passé en un an de
28 % à 48
% c'est pour ça que naturellement les
écologistes sont solidaires du mouvement
des agriculteurs sont solidaires de leur
lutte pour vivre dignement depuis 30 ans
les écologistes se battent contre les
accords de libre échange qui les
soumettent à une concurrence déloyale
revendiqu un revenu minimum souhaite
réformer la PAC et supprimer la dette
qui off ses
exploitants Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre seule réponse est de réduire les
protections environnementales ces normes
qui protègent la santé de nos paysans et
les terres qui cultive une réponse
inadaptée qui n'affronte pas l'agro
business choisir la facilité ne résoudra
rien la crise ne sera pas en rayé et le
déclin de l'agriculture française
continuera en bref depuis 7 ans vous
avez activement volontairement siamment
capituler face aux profiteurs des crises
alors mettons un mot sur votre politique
posons les mots et parlons d'égoïsme
pour un gouvernement qui enrichit une
ultra minorité au détriment du reste de
la nation posons les mots et parlons
d'impunité quand le président décide
d'utiliser son statut l'autorité de
l'institution qu'il représente la
visibilité dont il bénéficie pour
écraser la parole des femmes victimes
d'hommes considérés comme intouchable
posons les mots et parlons de déchéance
morale après l'adoption de la loi
immigration qui reprend les obsessions
et les mensonges de l'extrême droite
alors que ces ministres défilent dans
nos rues à Lyon à hy ou à Roman Surer
posons les mots et parlons
d'incompétence don vous êtes incapable
depuis un mois de nommer un ministre du
Logement et qu'au vu de vos annonces
vous allez encore fragiliser le logement
social et que vous annoncez tout au plus
30000 logements dans 20 territoires
alors qu'il en faut 500000 le 9 janvier
dernier vous vous adressiez monsieur le
Premier ministre à nous votre opposition
en ces termes nous avons en commun le
destin de notre nation sur ce point nous
nous retrouvons les décisions que nous
prenons ici et maintenant façonnerons
notre destin commun et celui de nos
enfants tout d'abord soyez assurés que
nous votre opposition de gauche et
écologiste défendons ensemble dans cette
assemblée une politique de progrès
social et de justice climatique ensemble
nous avons voté la hausse du SMIC la
prime alimentaire l'interdiction de
substanceces cancérigène l'interdiction
des jet privé et vous vous y êtes
systématiquement opposé pour que notre
destin soit grand pour que notre destin
soit beau c'est un changement radical
dont nous avons besoin car vos
capitulations successives ont amoindri
la France la France doit reprendre son
souffle elle doit aussi reprendre sa
place dans le concert des nations la
France était une boussole au niveau
international cette parole écouté a été
abîmée par la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron alors que la Cour internationale
de Justice alerte sur le risque de
génocide à Gaza la place de la France
est claire elle doit être du côté du du
droit de la raison de la paix et de la
vie la France doit activement uvrer pour
le retour des utage et doit exiger
fermement un cesser le feu immédiat et
permanent Victor Hugo définissait la
France de
1789 comme une grande lumière mise au
service d'une grande justice nous
écologistes nous battrons sans relâche
pour que la France redevienne la nation
qui lue de manière acharnée contre les
inégalités nous nous battrons pour que
la France se dresse enfin contre
l'accaparement des terres et de l'eau
que la France reste une terre d'accueil
qui protège et qui nous rend fier nous
continuerons à nous battre pour une
certaine idée de la France la France qui
ose la France qui n'a pas peur la France
qui s'entraide malgré vous malgré vos
annonces rétrogrades nous continuerons à
faire vivre la lumière de la
France merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente la parole est à présent à
monsieur le président igne pour le
groupe Gauche démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine madame la Présidente et
chers collègues monsieur le Premier
ministre lors de sa réélection en avril
2022 face au rassemblement national le
président Macron avait déclaré ce vote
m'oblige pour les années à venir depuis
cet engagement n'a trouvé d'écho ni dans
la politique menée ni dans la pratique
du pouvoir les élections législatives
avaient pourtant confirmé la nécessité
pour le camp présidentiel privé de
majorité absolue de gouverner autrement
et de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs le
mandat de Madame borne s'est au comp
inscrit dans la continuité de pratiques
brutale avec pour pratique nouvelle 23
493 et s'il fallait attribuer une PAL
elle serait décernée au 493 qui s'est
abattu sur la réforme des retraites
malgré l'opposition de 80 % des Français
et de la majorité de
l'hémicycle violence institutionnelle et
reniment des engagements tel est le
résumé de ce début de quinquena qui
s'est achevé en donnant à l'extrême
droite une victoire idéologique majeure
en CD dans toute honte bu au fantasme
avec l'adoption d'un texte sur
l'immigration contraire à la loi
fondamentale en créant un appel d' au
racisme tout en fragilisant notre État
de droit certes plus d'une trentaine de
mesures ont été censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais l'irréparable a
déjà été commis laissant derrière son
passage blessure et conséquence monsieur
le nouveau Premier ministre vous êtes
non seulement comptable de ce triste
bilan mais vous avez été désigné comme
commissaire politique par le Président
de la République pour poursuivre le vre
entamé le 16 janvier dernier il vous a
rappelé que le détenteur suprême du
pouvoir exécutif c'est
lui vous venez de le confirmer avec
votre gouvernement mondain de l'entre
soi vous servirez sa politique au
service des riches une politique qui
creuse toujours davantage les inégalités
avec fierté dites-vous sans jamais
douter avec arrogance c'est cette
feuille de route qui vous a été confié
et la vacance de temps de ministère de
votre gouvernement atteste de la
quintessence idéologique de ce projet
politique alors que l'hôpital public se
meurt que le non accès aux soins est
généralisé laissant pas moins de 6,7
millions de personnes sans médecins
traitant ce gouvernement ne compte pas
du ministère de la Santé de plein
exercice à nombre alors que le nombre de
travailleurs pauvres et d'emplois
précaires explose que les réformes
successives et C la venir menace
l'existence même d'un droit à
l'assurance chômage ce gouvernement ne
compte pas de ministère de travail de
plein exercice alors que la France
traverse une crise du logement d'une
ampleur inédite que le nombre de
personnes sans domicile a doublé en 10
ans que 3000 enfants dorment dans la rue
que 18 % de la population vit dans un
logement insalubre ce gouvernement ne
compte toujours pas de ministre de
logement alors alors que Lady outrem
taux de chômage est de à quat fois plus
élevé que dans l'Hexagone que si nourrir
y coûte 30 à 42 % plus cher que s'il
trouve les plus grands déserts médicaux
et que le scandale d'État du clordécone
atteint la réponse de votre gouvernement
toujours pas de portefeuille dédié à ces
territoires alors que notre pays a
besoin de mesure choc pour développer le
transport ferroviaire les transports en
commun à la hauteur des besoins dans
l'urgence transition écologique ce
gouvernement ne compte pas de ministre
des Transports alors que l'école
publique connaît une crise sans
précédent que près de 10000 enseignants
ont disparu depuis 2017 que la France
poursuit sa chute vertigineuse dans le
classement PISA pas de ministère de
plein d'exercice pour éducation
nationale pire le jour même de sa
nomination la ministre en charge de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports des Jeux Olympiques et par mp V
la ségrégation sociale et le tri social
humiliant au passage les enseignants du
public votre message monsieur le Premier
ministre est clair le règne de
l'héritocratie est désormais assumé et
le triomphe de l'oligarchie assurée
alors que les guerres bouleversent
l'ordre du monde que l'urgence à
l'action pour la paix nous constatons la
mise sous tutelle de ministre des
Affaires étrangères qui avoir pour seul
at tout d'avoir grandi à l'étranger pour
réussir dans sa tâche oh combien
difficile et essentielle pour le
rayonnement de la France à
l'international où sont vos propositions
pour réparer notre République abîmée
pour apaiser notre pays déchiré pour
répondre à la souffrance de la majeure
partie du peuple maltraité face au
désespoirs agriculteur vous avez fait le
Paris du coup de Come sur un ballot de
paille mais vos annonces sont pas vaincu
pas plus que celle d'aujourd'hui et pour
cause aucune mesure sérieuse pour
répondre sur la durée à la situation
catastrophique qu'ils affrontent rien
rien de concret sur les distorsions de
concurrence nourries par l'importation
massiv de produits qui ne respectent pas
les normes sociales ou sanitaires rien
sur les effets du libre échange des
traités de libre échange d assignés
seulement un vague engagement sur le
Mercosur en ignorant les autes notre
négociation en cours rien sur le revenu
des agriculteurs les prix planchés et
sur la révision en profondeur du cas des
négociations commercial je vous le dis
on ne dupe pas impunément ceux qui ne
veulent pas mourir pour pouvoir nourrir
et vous ne duperez pas non plus la
majorité des Françaises et des Français
qui ne se laisseront pas impressionné
par une litanie de mesurettes de court
terme alors qu'ils attend des réformes
de fond et de progrès social face à une
inflation qui atteint 20 % en cumulé sur
les deux dernières années avec des pics
encore plus importants pour les denrises
alimentaires et l'énergie face à la
smigartisation de la France face à la
paupérisation des travailleurs vous ne
proposez rien pour revoir de font en
comble notre système fiscal et garantir
une meilleure répartition des richesses
et de la valeur rien rien pour réduire
les écarts de revenus rien rien pour
pénaliser la rente financière améliorer
significativement le niveau de vie de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
bien au contraire vous nous annoncez
poursuivre dans la casse minutieuse de
notre modèle social vous allez laisser
respirer les entreprises avec moins de
normes et étouffer les chômeurs avec
moins de droit et vous avez oublié comme
par hasard de rappeler l'augmentation
des prix d'électricité et des franchises
médicales je vous le demande monsieur le
Premier ministre solennellement renoncer
à ses
augmentation face au drame qui se
déroule en Palestine et alors que la
Cour internationale de Justice a reconnu
le risque de génocide en cours dans la
bande de Gaza la France comme vous-même
reste desésespérément silencieus et
complaisantees à l'égard du gouvernement
israélien
ignorant le rôle que notre pays pourrait
jouer dans cette région pour retrouver
de sa grandeur passée vous
persister dans votre refus de
reconnaître l'état palestinien à appeler
un cesser le feu permanent mais vous
précipitez pour suspendre les aides à
l'unra et au réfugiés
palestiniens le fameux deux poids de
mesure est devenu la ligne de conduite
de la diplomatie française enfin vous
nous assurez vouloir être respectueux de
la représentation nationale mais
n'est-ce pas vous monsieur le Premier
ministre qui avvez inventé le 4 mai
dernier de conser avec votre Ministre de
tutelle Monsieur le Maire l'obstruction
gouvernementale pour empêcher l'adoption
de notre proposition de loi pour indexer
la DGF sur l'inflation n'est-ce pas vous
monsieur le Premier ministre
l'hypertrophie présidentielle associé à
la servitude de l'exécutif et à votre
pratique de la démocratie parlementaire
ne nous laisse que peu d'espoir Monsieur
le Premier Ministre votre refus de
soumettre votre déclaration de politique
générale au vote de la représentation
nationale anéanti à lui seul tous vos
efforts déployés à convaincre des atouts
de votre jeunesse pour diriger ce
gouvernement vous en avez la fougue mais
il vous manque le plus essentiel le
courage et le panache pour ce qui
concerne les députés du groupe GDR
communistes et progressistes des
territoires dit d'outrem nous resterons
fidèles aux engagements que nous avons
pris devant les Françaises et les
Français dans le combat entre l'ombre et
la lumière nous nous opposerons au
sabotage méthodique des valeurs qui ont
fait la grandeur de notre pays et de
notre République indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale nous resterons
fidèle à notre pratique parlementaire
travaillant sans relâche ici sur nos
territoires et sur nos territoires pour
être au plus près des besoins et des
préoccupations de celles ceux qui
souffrent nous déplirons toute notre
énergie pour réparer notre nation parce
que nous sommes pour reprendre m C du
côté de l'espérance mais d'une espérance
conquise lucide hors de toute naïveté
oui hors de toute naïveté ce qui nous
fait dire pour conclure tur sortez du
corps de notre premier ministre parce
que comme le dit le poète quand on est
réque on est
réque je vouscie
président la parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président Pancher pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre maire
et territoire madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
comme la plupart des collègues du groupe
Liot je suis allé sur un barage
d'agriculteurs en colère ces derniers
jours pour leur témoigner notre
solidarité notre soutien mon passage
n'était ni organisé par des services de
la préfecture ni filtré issu d'un
territoire rural fils d'agriculteur
ayant à l'esprit les graves difficultés
qu'ils affrontent et qui n'ont fait que
croître j'ai vu les visages graves comme
pour les professionnels de santé les
artisans ou les enseignants j'ai été
frappé par une colère amplifiée par
l'absence d'écoute et de concertation
après la crise des gilets jaunes celle
des retraites des banlieux cette
mobilisation c'est encore et encore un
appel à changer les modes de décision et
une soif de transformation de notre
logiciel
démocratique vous n'anticipez jamais et
vous ne savez pas écouter vous êtes dans
l'entre soie depuis les beaux quartiers
de Paris coupé de la réalité de nos
territoires que nous demandent nos
concitoyens que le travail pai enfin et
que vous maîtrisiez l'inflation touchant
de plus en plus de Françaises et de
français en difficulté mais aussi une
justice et un accompagnement social et
non pas marche ou crève comme il m'a
semblé l'entendre il y a quelques
instants de la simplification le stock
des normes à triplé en 20 ans des normes
qui s'additionnent se contredisent
mettre fin à la technocratie en folie
enfin un état qui se consacre qui se
concentre sur ses priorités seul 6 % de
l'investissement sur le régalien on
comprend mieux pourquoi nos hôpitaux la
justice l'enseignement nos commiss
sont dans un aussi mauvais état et que
l'on ne prépare pas l'avenir de nos
jeunes y compris au plan environnemental
cette crise institutionnelle ne peut pas
se ne peut se résoudre que par une
réforme profonde de l'État la priorité
un véritable choc de décentralisation
plus de consultation avec le référendum
un parlement plus respecté des corps
intermédiaires plus écoutés des dépenses
publes les plus importantes de tous les
pays occidentaux chez nous et des
services publics qui fonctionnent de
moins en moins bien quel
paradoxe les Français attendent des
mesures fortes sur le pouvoir d'achat le
partage de la valeur ajoutée et de la
participation ils veulent des hôpitaux
qui fonctionnent des épates qui ne
soient pas des mouroirs et des bonnes
écoles qui ne soient pas réservé qu'au
plus riche comme le président s'était
engagé nous demandons une vraie loi
grand âge une vraie politique du
logement permettre aux Français de se
loger soutenir la construction s'engager
enfin dans la rénovation énergétique
mais par une politique du logement en
regroupant et en simplifiant tous les
dispositifs la seule réponse enfin une
prise en compte des territoires
ultramarins comme nos territoires ruraux
toujours oubliés et négligés nous
demandons une véritable loi de
programmation pour nos territoires
ultramarins les coupures d'eau sont
insupportables comme les difficultés
d'accès aux soins du notamment à la
double insularité je ne vous ai pas
entendu non plus monsieur le Premier
ministre sur l'aménage des territoires
vous venez de prononcer votre discours
de politique générale 3 semaines après
votre nomination un catalogue en
oubliant petit détail que vous n'avez
toujours pas de majorité votre
gouvernement n'est toujours pas
constitué vous n'avez pas osé d'ailleurs
demander la confiance de notre assemblée
vos déclarations choc les surenchères
médiatiques et leur mise en scène où les
réponses à l'immédiateté des réseaux
sociaux ne seront contentés nos citoyen
à la recherche d'un CAP un véritable
développement enfin humain économique
social et environnemental et par une
méthode claire celle de l'écoute et de
la
concertation mais cela fait 7 ans que
vous êtes au pouvoir et même si cela
fait déjà 7 ans que vous êtes au pouvoir
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire pour travailler sur les priorités
pour notre pays ces trois prochaines
années nous y sommes prêts pas une liste
à la prèverre pour associer tous les
corps intermédiaires et les forces vives
de notre pays nous vous n demandons un
calendrier précis sur les réformes
institutionnelles le transfert de
compétences y compris réglementaires aux
grandes collectivités et leur autonomie
fiscale c'est la clé de la réussite pour
la France sans oublier la question de
l'autonomie pour la Corse nous croyons
dur comme faire monsieur le Premier
ministre que notre pays n'est pas in
gouvernable que notre pays est
réformable et que et rien n'est
inéluable sous réserve enfin que vous
entendiez les Françaises et les Français
avec le président Macron vous êtes
maintenant au pied du mur il y a deux
portes la première vous permettra de
monter un à un tous les escaliers du
redressement de notre pays à condition
de le faire dans la concertation la
deuxième s'ouvre face à un grand
précipice un saut qui sera pour notre
pays sans parachute écoutez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre écoutez les Françaises
et les Français et surtout ne vous
trompez pas de
porte merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président Maillard pour le
groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance rien dit
enc madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres alors que vous prononcez
devant cette assemblée votre discours de
politique générale il est clair que 2024
sera une année
décisive pour notre continent d'abord
avec la tenue d'un scrutin qui
déterminera l'Europe que nous
voulons pour notre pays ensuite alors
que les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
de Paris feront rayonner la France à
travers le monde
pour notre avenir enfin puisque les
politiques que nous aurons à voter et à
mettre en place dès maintenant
définiront le visage de notre nation
pour les décennies à venir c'est dans ce
contexte plein d'enjeux et de défis que
vous avez été nommé monsieur le Premier
ministre et cette nomination symbolise
pour les députés Renaissance autant une
marque de renouvellement que de
fidélité de fidélité oui à l'égard de
cette majorité parlementaire dont vous
êtes issu cette majorité qui en 7 ans a
créé 2 millions d'emplois et fait de
l'objectif du plein emploi un but
atteignable et non un vœux
pieux cette
majorité cette majorité qui est celle
qui a entamé la réindustrialisation de
notre pays avec l'installation de plus
de 300 nouvelles usines sur notre
territoire celle qui investit dans notre
souveraineté énergétique en relançant
notre filière nucléaire et en
développant les énergies renouvelables
comme jamais auparavant celle qui a
permis un renfoncement des effectifs de
notre police et de notre justice dans
des proportion inédite depuis 30 ans et
redonner à nos armées les moyens
d'assurer leur mission aux quatre coins
du
globe c'est cette majorité qui a accru
l'égalité des chances dans le
dédoublement des classes et l'école
inclusive et qui lutte depuis 7 ans
contre les déserts médicaux avec la
suppression du numéros clausus et la
libération du temps médical mais nous
devons aller plus loin vous avez fait
Monsieur le Premier Ministre des
annonces fortes devant nous celles qui
ont su protéger nos concitoyens et nos
entreprises lors de la crise du covid-19
comme nous les protégeons encore
aujourd'hui face à l'inflation plus
qu'aucun autre pays
européen cette majorité qui a fait de la
France le premier pays d'Europe en terme
d'investissement tout en accélérant la
transition
avec la baisse de plus de 4 % de nos
émissions de CO2 en 2023
oui 4 % nous sommes dans la
trajectoire celle qui a voté les moyens
de protéger notre souveraineté
alimentaire avec les lois égalim j'y
reviendrai je pourrais multiplier j'y
reviendrai je pourrais multiplier les
exemples de notre action résolu depuis 7
ans pour libérer pour protéger et
transformer notre pays
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous vous
inscrivez dans notre dans cette histoire
et vous avez désormais avec votre
gouvernement à en écrire une nouvelle
page et vous avez d'emblé voulu vous
inscrire sous la prime sous le prisme de
l'action et du concret c'est une
nécessité tant la politique risque de
mourir de ce paradoxe celui de ne pas
oser dire les choses d'un côté et de
l'autre d'en dire trop au risque de se
perdre dans le discours au détriment
plus que tout les temps que nous vivons
imposent que nous soyons dans le faire
davantage que dans le dire dans l'action
plutôt que dans
l'incantation Monsieur le Premier
Ministre parce que nous partageons le
même constat nous attendons de vous que
votre action prenne toujours en compte
la réalisation du dernier
kilomètre celui sans lequel il n'est pas
concevable de pouvoir changer réellement
la vie des
Français vos paroles devant cette
et vos premières décisions constituent
une preuve de l'importance que vous
accordez à cet impératif et il aura
s'incarner dans les nombreux domaines
qui définiront la France de
demain l'un des plus essentiels pour
notre pays premier producteur européen
c'est bien sûr l'agriculture dans un
monde aux échanges ultra
compétitifs nous devons continuer à
défendre l'excellence des produits
français en imposant les mêmes normes de
qualité aux pays qui veulent importer
leur Drée chez nous les députés
Renaissance veulent ces clauses miroir
pour qu'il soit impossible d'importer
des produits qui ne correspondent pas à
nos normes et nous
saluons et nous saluons votre
détermination à les instaurer dans nos
échanges
commerciaux c'est cette préoccupation
d'une alimentation de qualité qui nous a
posé poussé à déposer une proposition de
loi sur le bien manger qui sera votée
ici dans cette assemblée en mars
prochain mais pour que notre agriculture
prospère il faut avant tout que ceux qui
la font vivre puissent vivre de cette
activité sans craindre le
lendemain pour cela en tant que
législateur nous ne pouvons tolérer que
les lois votées par la représentation
nationale soi contourné voire
bafoué aussi nous saluons votre volonté
de faire respecter par les distributeurs
les transformateurs et les industriels
les lois ég lime ainsi que la loi que
nous avons porté pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grande
consommation nous serons à vos côtés
pour défendre l'agriculture exiger
qu'elle soit rémunérée à sa juste
valeur et nous continuerons dans les
semaines à venir à nous faire le relais
des préoccupations des maréchés des
éleveurs des viticulteurs des céréaliers
de l'ensemble des agriculteurs et des
pêche
de nos
territoires pour porter des textes qui
améliorent leur quotidien tel que la
proposition de loi renaissance pour
protéger le mode de vie agricole face au
troubles du voisinage dans cette
perspective nous nous appliquerons à
enrchir toujours plus la future loi
d'orientation agricole et apporter des
mesures qui changeront concrètement et
rapidement la situation de ceux qui nous
nourrissent ce choc des facilités que
nous voulons pour notre agriculture
il doit aussi se faire au bénéfice de
l'ensemble des concitoyens et des
entreprises de notre pays sans oublier
les collectivités
locales la bureaucratie est un poison
lorsqu'il alimente le désordre au lieu
de le
résoudre à la suite de la crise du covid
nous avons commencé à lever certaines
lenteur à remettre en cause des
procédure sans logique c'est cet élan
qu' nous faut conserver dans la nouvelle
loi de simplification nous serons
évidemment au rendez-vous pour l'amender
et
l'accentuer ce chantier de la
simplification nous permettra ainsi de
modifier profondément la vie nos
concitoyens tout en maintenant notre
objectif de redressement des finances
publiques la bonne tenue de nos comptes
est un impératif absolu de notre
majorité et nous tiendrons ensemble
monsieur le Premier ministre le
désendettement que nousous sommes fixés
cette trajectoire que nous sommes fixés
jusqu'en
plus que tout pour permettre à notre
pays de prospérer il faut vous l'avez
martelé dans votre discours redonner
toute sa pertinence à la valeur
travail d'abord en faisant en sorte que
le travail paye et en refusant de
laisser des millions de salariés
s'enfoncer dans la
précarité nous ne pouvons tolérer que
ceux qui respectent notre contrat social
et contribuent chaque jour à faire
tourner nos entreprises connaissent les
angoisses des fins de mois
cette classe moyenne qui est le pilier
de notre économie et qui se sent trop
souvent la grande oubliée de nos
politiques
publicque à cet égard les mesures que
vous avez annoncé ici Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vont dans le bon sens
car le travail doit toujours payer plus
que
l'inactivité ce combat pour le travail
il est au cœur du projet que les député
Renaissance défend depuis 7 ans car il
est l'essence même de l'émancipation de
Ch chacun et il sera déterminant pour
améliorer durablement le pouvoir d'achat
des Français qui est leur principale
préoccupation et qui doit donc être la
nôtre en métropole comme en outreem
essentiel aussi dans cette quête
d'émancipation est l'accès pour tous à
un logement or la crise que connaît
actuellement ce secteur impose que nous
apportions des réponses fortes aux
Français les textes que notre groupe a
porté ces derniers mois qu'il s'agisse
de la proposition contre l'occupation
illicite ou celle sur les meublés
touristiques constitue des premières
briques nous plons depuis longtemps pour
franchir un cap un véritable choc de
l'offre vous le savez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous étiez attendu sur
ce sujet vous y avez répondu par des
annonces
fortes un autre impératif un droit
fondamental même c'est le droit à la
sécurité aucun habitant ne devrait
craindre de se promener dans son
quartier aucune femme devrait craindre
de rentrer seule le soir aucun citoyen
ne devrait être victime d'incivilité
voire de violence dans l'espace
public aucun Français ne devrait
craindre de représaill du simple fait de
sa confession à tous nous devons leur
assurer quel que soit leur lieu de
résidence leur genre ou leur religion
qu'il puissent vivre en paix dans leur
pays les députés renaissances y
contribueront dès ce printemps avec une
proposition de loi renforçant la réponse
pénale contre les infractions à
caractère raciste ou antisémite et un
autre allongeant la durée de
l'ordonnance de protection pour les
victimes de violence
conjugale j'ai commencé à énumérer les
chantiers de court terme mais je
n'oublie naturellement pas ceux qui ont
vocation à s'inscrire dans le temps long
car ils sont au fondement même de notre
identité
parmi eux le premier bien sûr l'école
car c'est auprès des jeunes générations
que se joue notre avenir des jeunes
générations à qui monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez d'emblé dit que vous
vouliez redonner des causes d'espérance
nous ne pouvons qu'y souscrire pour cela
l'école est primordiale et pour lui
redonner toute sa place nous devons
jamais oublier hésiter à changer ce qui
doit l'être à bousculer les schémas
lorsqu'ils sont imparfaits à donner les
moyens à nos enseignants aux
établissements de valoriser ce qui
fonctionne cet investissement du
politique il faut qu'il se traduise dans
tous les servic public partout sur les
territoires notamment en matière de
santé car la première cause du sentiment
d'abandon de beaucoup c'est le manque
d'accès aux soins je l'ai dit notre
majorité a déjà agi pour inverser la
tendance et comme vous l'avez souligné
dans votre discours il nous faudra
accentuer cet effort nous serons à vos
côtés pour cela
un autre défi de notre temps le plus
grand sans doute c'est le changement
climatique vous avez en responsabilité
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la planif
exposer la planification
écologique ce sera essentiel pour
promouvoir une écologie de l'innovation
et de solution plutôt qu'une écologie de
l'obligation l'économ l'écologie doit
rimer avec ambition écologie ne doit
jamais rimer avec
décroissance car oui nous ne pouvons
nous ne devons pas abandonner notre
ambition écologique mais celle-ci ne
doit jamais se faire au détriment des
Français il faut aussi redonner aux
citoyens le goût de l'engagement c'est
ce que notre majorité s'emploie à faire
en votant cette semaine la proposition
de loi visant à soutenir l'engagement
bénévole ainsi que la proposition de loi
visant à reconnaître les métiers de la
médiation sociale
votre décision de péreniser les cours
d'éducation civique à l'école constitue
également un signe extrêmement
encourageant de même la généralisation
du SNU que vous venez d'annoncer ce
besoin d'engagement il se fait aussi
sentir dans notre démocratie cela impose
de revaloriser ceux qui la font vivre il
n'est pas concevable que dans notre pays
les élus soient impunément l'objet
d'insulte de menac de vel de violence
pour ne pas dire de
l'inchage servir ses concitoyens au sein
de sa commune de son département de sa
région où dans cette assemblée ne
devrait jamais faire craindre pour sa
vie ou pour celle de ses proches une
démocratie qui se retourne contre ceux
qui la servent elle se détruit et honte
à ceux qui par leur comportement
outranciers ont pu y compris sur ses
bancs alimenter ses bas
instincts à cet égard proposition de loi
renforçant la sécurité des élus locaux
sera
salutaire car le retour de l'autorité
passe nécessairement par le respect
envers les institutions et leurs
représentants pour mener à bien toutes
ces entreprises l'esprit de compromis
qui exige la configuration de notre
assemblée apparaît
indispensable je le redis aujourd'hui
devant l'ensemble des groupes de l'arc
républicain ma main et celle des députés
Renaissance est toujours tendu pour
construire des majorités de
projets nous le faisons déjà à travers
plusieurs textes transpartisan il nous
faut accentuer cet
élan mais pour conduire toutes ces
réformes un autre élément consubstantiel
au projet que nous portons depuis 2017
m' paraî
essentiel car Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la France a besoin d'audace
d'audace pour tenir le qui dans le
concert des nations et en Europe
d'audace pour préserver l'art de vivre à
la française et faire valoir ses idéaux
face au bouleversement du monde d'audace
pour se réinventer sans cesse en accord
avec son histoire et ses valeurs et
parce que votre action entend s'inscrire
dans la vision du président de la
République d'une France fière
d'elle-même je veux vous assurer ici du
soutien et de la confiance des députés
renaissance pour terminer mon propos
monsieur le Premier ministre
je veux vous lancer cet appel le même
que Danton fit jadis à la
tribune de l'audace encore de l'audace
toujours de l'audace et la France est
sauvée je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame la
présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues
l'exercice auquel nous venons d'assister
tient du rituel un rituel presque
mécanique et qui l' plus encore
aujourd'hui un catalogue une succession
de promesses diverses et variées sans
lien entre est de niveau pour le moins
inégal assez éloigné d'un discours de
politique
générale mais ce n'est pas faire un jour
à Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
constater que son intervention n'est que
la revue de détail d'une déclaration de
politique générale que le Président de
la République avait fait avant lui et du
coup à sa place à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse fleuve oh vous
comme nous et surtout comme le pays
subissons l'intempérance
jupitérienne il est vrai que le nouvel
équilibre institutionnel du quinena a
trop souvent ravalé et c'est malheureux
le rôle du Premier ministre à celui d'un
simple figurant un communiquant un
collaborateur comme dirait un ancien
président avec Emmanuel Macron cette
atrophie institutionnelle est encore
aggravé par la conception autocentrée
qu'il se fait du pouvoir le président
est ministre de tout évidemment le
premier d'entre eux pour aller
directement au fait je n'ai pas vu dans
ce discours de politique générale qui
tombe lourdement d'une des fenêtres du
château les voies et moyens du
redressement je n'ai pas senti le grand
souffle qui puisse emporter le pays vers
des lendemains heureux et pour tout dire
je n'ai senti aucun souffle il ne suffit
pas d'invoquer une volonté de mettre fin
au conservatisme pour bousculer un
système sclérosé par des décennies de
politiquement correct de connivance de
bétonnage de rendre de situation pas
toujours les légitime force de constater
que non seulement vous n'y êtes pas
parvenu mais tout au contraire vous
poursuivez un modèle andogamique et
oligarchique dont votre Ministre madame
ouea Castera apparaît comme
l'incarnation archétypale et puis il y a
le fond la valangeche de promesses à
laquelle nous venons d'assister ne nous
laisse entrevoir qu'une réponse à
quelques urgence médiatique comme s'il
s'agissait de gagner du temps je ne vois
rien en effet qui contribue au
redressement des piliers effondrés vous
continuez à porter une vision
utilitariste construite autour de
mesurett sans transcendance ni porter et
surtout une vision fondamentalement
postptique et post nationale dans ce
catalogue de mesur épart et parfois
contradictoire vous tentez d'allier un
peu de droite et un peu de gauche et en
réalité vous accommoder le pire de la
droite et le pire de la
gauche le pire de la
droite c'est par exemple la Haus des
franchises
ou la nouvelle réforme à venir du
chômage le pire de la gauche la hausse
des taxes sur l'électricité ou la
normalisation à harange je pense bien
sûr au DPE qui fait tant de mal au
secteur du logement et le bilan
financier de vos politiques est apparu
il y a quelques jours un déficit
budgétaire de l'État proche du record de
l'année
2020 la situation exige une remise à
plat d'une autre ampleur un grand
mouvement appuyé sur une volonté
nationale sur la force retrouvée de
l'État et sur une volonté populaire qui
légitime l'action publique en clair la
souveraineté l'état la
démocratie la première condition est de
rendre au Pays sa capacité de décider et
votre armage aveugle et inconditionnel
sur l'agenda bruxellois vous condamne
d'office aux mêmes herments que vos
prédécesseurs à quoi RIM les discours
sur le volontarisme lorsque vous savez
que vous avez laissé les commandes int
et institutionnel à l'autorité
supranationale de l'Union
européenne à quoi bon les déclarations
sur l'agriculture au-dessus de tout
lorsque vous êtes prisonnier des
logiques décroissantistes du wisme vert
appuyz sur des ballots de paille vous
parlez de souveraineté française quand
l'Élysée use et abuse d'un oxymort d'une
incantation antinomique la souveraineté
européenne alors que la trèsmercantile
Union européenne a depuis toujours
révoqué le mot souveraineté pour s'en
remettre de manière obsessionnelle à la
seule loi du marché pensez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre qu'au moment même où
les agriculteurs français manifestaient
à Bruxelles devant le Parlement européen
à quelques mètres de là dans un immeuble
en vert vos élus du groupe Renaissance
votai un nouvel accord de libre échange
désastreux avec le
Chili cela ne vous empêchez pas le
lendemain la main sur le cœur de
promettre aux agriculteurs français de
les
défendre les commentateurs amusés ils
verront les artifices du en même temps
moi ces faux semblant m'inspire la plus
grande peine pour nos agriculteurs pour
cette France rurale qui souffre pour
notre peuple que l'on trompe la
confiance pourtant si nécessaire en ces
temps de crise ne peut revenir dans
votre monde où l' privilégie le court
terme l'éphémère l'apparence et où l'on
pense pouvoir éteindre les contestations
par des initiatives dilatoires le
mensonge la ruse ou à l'usure il ne sert
à rien de vouloir écoper le bateau qui
fait haut quand les membres de
l'équipage aux ordres du commandant
s'active en même temps à ouvrir des
voies d'eau partout dans la
coque quel crédit peut-on accorder à ces
incohérences avez-vous comme premier
ministre seulement pris
sur ce qui se passe sur ce qui est
décidé sur ce système qui a fait le
choix résolu de la vassalisation à
Bruxelles du pacte vert au Pacte des
migration vos choix politiques
ressemblent de plus en plus à des pactes
faustien on se perd en conjecture sur
les bénéfices que vous en tirez à moins
que comme fa il s'agisse seulement de
gagner un peu plus de temps de
jouissance il est parfois
compliqué de comprendre ce qu'est le
macronisme et vraisemblablement beaucoup
même les observateurs avertis seraient
incapable d'en donner une définition
précise une chose est sûre il s'agit
d'une pensée liquide avec pour
perspective une société liquide parce
que pour
vous tout doit se résumer à des flux la
théorie du ruissellement vous sert à
servir les nentill le seul ruissellement
qu'il y a eu c'est celui de l'argent
public qui a coulé à flot avec votre cap
vous avez pour perspective de noyer la
France dans l'océan de la dette 900
milliards de dettes supplémentaires en 7
ans autant que le montant total de la
dette française en l'an
2000 cette liquidité que vous prenez
mène et c'est logique à la liquidation
Emmanuel Macron en tête vous mettez en
œuvre la grande déconstruction le grand
effacement de la France comme des
somnambules sans tenir compte des
réalités sociales ou de l'évolution du
monde qui s'ajoute à l'abrasion
naturelle du temps quand rien dans la
décision politique ne conduit au
dépassement la première condition vous
disaisje c'était la souveraineté la
seconde condition c'est la restauration
de l'État et de ce point de vue je ne
vois pas dans votre déclaration de lueur
d'espoir la restauration de l'État
suppose de sortir de la grande confusion
politicoadministrative qui règne dans
nos institutions nationales ou locales
il est urgent de remettre de l'ordre
dans l'organisation publique avec le
gouvernement des sachant dont le
saintsimonisme ambiant a fait une
religion en France et en Europe on
assiste à un va et vien entre fonction
administrative et politique entre
fonction publique et intérêts privés
entre fonctions électives et autres
magistrature il en résulte une confusion
profonde une confusion dommageable pour
la gestion publique mais aussi la
crédibilité de les institutions leur
solidité leur
efficacité confusion politique lorsque
les politiques ont abdiqué leur
responsabilité et que le mot politique
devient synonyme
d'impuissance confusion institutionnelle
lorsque plus personne ne sait qui fait
quoi qui décide de quoi et même qui est
en état juridiquement de décider le
local le National le Parlement le
président le juge le Conseil
constitutionnel Bruxelles la presse
l'OTAN comble de paradoxe sous la 5è qui
lui en a qui lui en donne le pouvoir le
président ne préside pas il gouverne et
lors que le président gouverne le
gouvernement se contente d'administrer
les affaires courantes que dire des
régions qui ouvrent des ambassades à
l'étrangers des communes qui
subventionnent sans objet municipal le
trafic d'êtres humains par le biais des
associations complices des passeurs d'un
clan politique qui saccage la capitale
de tous les Français d'un préfet de
police qui est incable de faire cesser
les vendeurs à la sauvette sous la tour
eel ou d'une préfecture qui entretient
des rapports troubles avec des individus
impliqués dans l'acte terroriste de
treèb pour nous au rassemblement
national il n'y a de restauration de la
puissance publique qu'à deux conditions
la restauration de la fonction publique
la restauration des moyens de l'État la
question la grande question qui est
posée au pays n'est pas seulement le
programme de tel ou tel gouvernement ce
n'est pas la vision seulement de tel ou
tel président ce n'est pas la bonne
volonté supposée et ou réel de tel ou
tel ministre c'est le retour du
politique c'est au politique qu'il
appartient de décider et tout
particulièrement dans les ministères
dans les assemblées dans les régions ou
dans les communes l'élu doit arrêter de
se tourner vers le fonctionnaire pour se
faire souffler une décision et encore
moins une injonction les ministres
doivent cesser d'être les portes parole
Serville des directeurs d'administration
des féodalités bancaires de la grande
distribution
des intêts financi ils doivent redevenir
les inspirateurs des grandes impulsions
publiques don le pays a besoin le retour
du politique c'est aussi congédier la
pensée magique celle du quoi qu'il en
coûte ou celle du suffit d'emprunter
celle des experts ou des grands prêtres
de la pensée unique la logique frileuse
et désastreuse du pas de vague quand il
s'agit d'affronter les problèmes à
l'heure où vous parlez de réarmement
peut-être pour vous donner des air
guerriers je ne crois pas avoir entendu
l'expression réarmement régalien ce
n'est pas un oubli parce que ce n'est
pas votre projet pourtant la question
est d'importance la France est-elle
condamnée à s'enfoncer dans le laxisme
judiciaire la politique peut-il
peut-elle encore continuer à demander à
la police de terrain les solutions
sécuritaires et sociales qui relèvent
justement du politique et de lui seul
l'entreprise peut-elle supplier les
carences de formation et parfois même
d'éducation
C au politiques au pluriel de reprendre
conscience de leur rôle et confiance
dans leur vocation qui est celle de
décider librement de la vie de la cité
des régulations nécessaires des
sanctions lorsqu'elle participe au juste
et nécessaire équilibre social mais
c'est vrai cela demande du courage pour
reprendre le cardinal de Richelieu
fondateur de l'État la politique revient
à rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
cela exige de la
persévérance le retour du
politique implique en réalité la
détermination à reprendre le contrôle à
le reprendre sur les forces
supranationales comme l'Union européenne
sur les féodalités qui gangrainent la
vie sociale et
économique sur les inerties
administrative ou d'habitude sur la
résignation de l'opinion lassé des
échecs de ces dirigeants et le moyen le
bras armé de cette reprise de contrôle
c'est l'état pour peu qu'il soit
respecté c'est-à-dire restauré
la restauration de l'État c'est la
réhabilitation des grands corps
préfectoral ou corps diplomatique le
retour du sens de l'État et au plus près
des gens partout sur le territoire en
métropole et en outrem la proximité des
services publics c'est un Attac
conscient qui n'agit pas pour lui mais
au service de la nation un état
conscient que son premier devoir est la
sécurité intérieure et extérieure
l'égalité des citoyens et la liberté de
tous c'est un état
dont les agents sont honorés respectés
et récompensés comme le mérite le
service qu'il consacre au pays c'est un
état doté des moyens de ses
missions la troisème condition du
redressement c'est la démocratie
c'est-à-dire le retour du peuple ou de
ses représentants quoi que vous puissiez
dire sur votre prétendu changement de
méthode Monsieur le Premier Ministre on
ne peut que constater votre incapacité à
sortir des logiques verticales à votre
décharge après c ans de pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron je ne crois pas que
vous puissiez modifier ce qui apparaît
être une marque de fabrique du
macronisme votre discours sonnait
d'ailleurs comme un cruel réquisitoire
des 7 ans d'Emmanuel Macron vous n'avez
pas de majorité au lieu d'en chercher
une par le respect de vos alliés par
l'écoute par le dialogue et
éventuellement par le compromis vous
comptez sur des ruses institutionnelles
en excluant par principe les voies
transparentes et saines de trouver
l'assise majoritaire dont vous avez
besoin l'élaboration de la loi par des
493 la mitrailleuse les décisions
publiques marteau ou les atteintes au
droit d'amendement au nom de prétendu
cavalier ne sont pas admissibles dans
une démocratie moderne lorsque le
Conseil constitutionnel participe au
détricotage arbitraire de l'expression
de la représentation parlementaire par
une lecture militante de la Constitution
il en ressort une impression de dénis
démocratique un piétinement du principe
même de la
démocratie enfin qui peut croire que le
délit de séjour irrégulier n'aurait rien
à voir avec l'immigration et à ce titre
devrait être effacé de la loi un pays ne
peut pas sans conséquence psychologique
passer des lois sans vote et parfois
sans débat ignorer les contestations
sociales réprimer l'expression des
souffrances populaires ou jouer avec une
délectation cynique la stratégie du
pourrissement le respect de la volonté
du peuple fondement de la démocratie nul
ne devrait pouvoir s'en
affranchir vous devez cesser de
considérer l'exercice de la démocratie
comme une formalité
administrative la conduite de l'État
comme un pass-ant les institutions comme
des instruments les fonctions
ministérielles comme un jeu de chaise
musicale ce que nous attendons d'un
gouvernement c'est qu'il définisse
clairement la grande voie autour de
laquelle doit s'articuler tout action
publique toute projection pour l'avenir
nous n'avons rien vu de tout cela ni
depuis 7 ans ni
aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente Panau pour le groupe la
France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Ministre
collègues vous nous avez maintenu dans
l'attente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
plus de 2 semaines avant de vous
entendre délivrer un discours de
politique générale que vous devez à la
représentation nationale bien entendu
vous ne demandez pas la confiance à
l'Assemblée ce qui serait le minimum que
l'on pourrait attendre si notre
démocratie fonctionnait vous ne demandez
pas la confiance car vous ne l'avez pas
vous n'avez ni la confiance de
l'Assemblée ni celle des citoyens vous
nous avez maintenu dans l'attente mais
vous vous êtes rendu compte entre-temps
que personne ne vous attendait les
agriculteurs en colère ne vous ont pas
attendu pour lancer un mouvement pour
vivre de leur travail leur avez-vous dit
que votre majorité avait rejeté une loi
que nous avions proposé en novembre
dernier pour encadrer les marges de
l'industrie agroalimentaire et surtout
garantir des prix rémunérateurs pour eux
leur avez-vous parlé de votre duplicité
ù vous êtes-vous contenté d'une mise en
scène poussive pathétique et
immédiatement échoué entre une botte de
faim et un verre de vin rouge sur une
autoroute beau coup de communication ne
font pas une politique vous venez
d'ailleurs encore une fois de le montrer
avec votre discours de propagande
générale les professeurs ne vous ont pas
d'avantage attendu ils seront en grève
ce jeudi 1er février épuisés par
l'application de vos improvisation
ministérielle et atterré par la nouvelle
ministre qu'Emmanuel Macron et vous-même
leur avez choisi cette nouvelle ministre
est à elle seule un symbole de
l'ensemble de votre gouvernement de vos
politiques passées et à venir elle donne
votre adresse de classe au archie c'est
par ici haute bourgeoisie vous y voilà
fille du directeur de Publicis femme du
directeur général de la Société générale
puis de s fille cousine d'une
éditorialiste de BFM TV niè d'une
éditorialiste bien connu du service
public présidente de la Fédération
française de tennis pour 500000 € par an
avant de devenir ministre des Sports
puis tout récemment de l'éducation
nationale des sports des Jeux Olympiques
et paralympique la pauvre nous
disait-elle elle gagit tro fois plus
avant merci de nous avoir offert une si
belle caricature de votre politique de
l'oligarchie que vous êtes représenté et
défendé quand on lui parle de sa défense
lamentable de ces mensonges à répétition
dans cette affaire du lcé Stanislas ou
des thèses réactionnaires et hostille à
la République sont répandu elle dit ne
pas avoir menti non tenez-vous bien
c'est la réalité qui lui donne tort en
la matière vous êtes des experts en
matière de politique économique et
sociale d'écologie de démocratie
la réalité vous donne toujours tort mais
vous continuez la réalité vous donne
encore tort vous continuez vous mentez
de nouveau vous continuez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre madame oua Castera
partage avec vous un arrondissement du
lycée Stanislas à l'École alsacienne on
se comprend bien entre grand bourgeois
madame ouia castira n'est pas encore
parti pour une bonne raison vous êtes
tous comme elle alors pourquoi serait- à
l'elle de s'en aller la première elle
pense ne devoir rien à personne et sans
doute doit-elle vivre son ministère
comme une peine infinie car elle y gagne
encore moins qu'à la Fédération
Française de Tennis peut-être peut-être
les effets cumulés de votre suppression
de l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
compense-t-il toutefois cette perte de
revenu
ouf Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'étymologie de ministre est simple
permettez-moi de vous la rappeler ce nom
vient de ministère serviteur en latin
tout gouvernement doit être un
gouvernement de serviteur vous êtes un
gouvernement de serviteur sans aucun
doute mais vous ignorez quand démocratie
c'est le peuple que les ministres
doivent servir au lieu de cela vous vous
servez vous-même et les plus riches dont
les intérêts ne se sont jamais aussi
bien portter en 5e République que sous
Emmanuel Macron la fortune des 500
familles les plus riches de ce pays a
plus que doublé depuis 2017 vous en êtes
les serviteurs aés mais vous oubliez la
République et ses principes vous
préférez jeter en pâture celles et ceux
qui arrivent sur notre territoire pour
ne pas parler des inégalités croissantes
du problème massif du lovement des
sansabri des travailleurs si nombreux
dont la paix ne suffit plus de la
situation sociale insupportable que vos
politiques injustes font subir au pays
vous n'êtes monsieur le Premier ministre
à la hauteur ni de la situation sociale
ni de notre histoire démocratique et
encore moins de l'impérative nécessité à
transformer nos modes de production pour
répondre à l'immense défi écologique
vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur une partie de la presse
sympathisante sans doute de votre
gouvernement minoritaire pont des
portraits ridicules de vous Monsieur le
Premier Ministre où l'on s'extasie du
fait que vous dormiez peu c'est
peut-être pour cela que le pays semble
conduit par une équipe de somnambule
ensommeillé dans leur rêve de
milliardaires éblouis par les lumières
télévisuelles vivant dans un spectacle
permanent que le pays regarde avec
consternation mais pendant que vous
vivez de l'esbrouff éternelle le pays
souffre vos tentatives d'hypnose ne
fonctionne pas les agriculteurs à bout
comprennent que le libre échange la
défense par une poignée d'un un modèle
intenable les marges les est sans
contrôle sont la source de leur
difficulté quotidiennes les enseignants
voient se créer vos groupes de niveau
idée aussi stigmatisante qu'inefficace
sur le plan pédagogique comprennent le
caractère systématique de la destruction
du service public qu'ils honorent les
chemineaux que vous avez vilipandé dont
vous avez dégradé la condition sociale
voit disparaître un petit feu le service
public ferroviaire que vous avez détruit
méthodiquement pour libéraliser le rail
conformément au directec
européenne les salariés du privé
souffrent toujours davantage du partage
violemment injuste de la valeur produite
les soignants et personnels du secteur
médico-social constate en dépit de leur
engagement quotidien votre obstination à
mettre en pièce le service public de la
santé les chômeurs patiss à chacune de
vos réformes d'avantage de la violence
que vous leur infligez et de la
situation économique qui leur laisse le
choix entre la précarité ou la honte que
vos discours d'exclusion leur renvoi
toujours les jeunes pour le climat vois
votre incompréhension totale de
l'ampleur des changements nécessaires
pour faire face au dérèglements
climatiques et à l'extinction de masse
des espèces les retraité s'inquiète des
coups de canif que vous avez mis dans le
contrat social qui unit entre elles les
générations notre magnifique système de
retraite par
répatition Monsieur le Premier Ministre
c'est le peuple tout entier qui n'en
peut plus de vos politiques elles ont
toutes la même source le refus d'engager
le partage des richesses pour rémunérer
le travail engager les investissements
nécessaires pour les burcation
écologique et reconstruire nos services
publics vous déstabilisez profondément
notre société en vous en vous les
éloignant loin bien loin de la
République sociale vous resterez dans
l'histoire comme le pouvoir qui a ramené
la France à un pays qui a faim à un pays
où les gens meurent de la rue meurent du
travail meurent sur des brancards
d'hôpitaux une alternative existe
monsieur le Premier ministre et le fait
que vous ne demandiez pas la confiance
en est la preuve vous êtes minoritaire
vous le savez vous nous avez fait
attendre mais personne n'attend plus
rien de vous à vous et aux citoyens qui
nous écoutent à cette heure je l'affirme
une alternative existe oui il est
possible d'engager une toute autre
politique augmenter le SMIG à 1600 € net
convoquer une conférence générale
d'augmentation des salaires porter l'âge
de la retraite à 60 ans pour 40 annuité
investir massivement dans les services
publ dans l'isolation thermique des
logements les énergies renouvelables
dans un pôle public de l'énergie ou en
dans la formation et l'installation de
nouveaux paysans comme l'annulation de
la dette des agriculteurs pour la
conversion sociale et écologique tout
cela est possible alors je vous entends
déjà comment accomplir et financer cela
c'est simple en cessant de servir ce que
vous servez en taxant le capital en
rétablissement l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune en créant de nouvelles
tranches d'impôts sur le revenu pour les
plus riches de notre pays en rendant
progressive la contribution sociale
généralisée en un mot en organisant le
partage des richesses
une telle perspective peut vous sembler
abominable mais c'est pourtant la clé de
la cohésion du pays aujourd'hui vous en
êtes le facteur de division abusant des
pouvoirs que vous donne l'actuelle
Constitution la 5e République vous rend
d'ailleurs plus invisible que vous le
souhaiteriez sans doute Monsieur le
Premier Ministre personne n'ignore que
tout se décide à l'Élysée jusqu'au
discours que vous venez de prononcer
Monsieur le Premier Ministre relu anoté
et corrigé par le monarque lui-même
Emmanuel Macron est le serviteur en chef
et vous êtes à ses ordres comme
d'ailleurs une bonne partie de la
minorité parlementaire qui a crubon de
voter il y a quelques semaines une loi
reprenant le principe de préférence
nationale défendu par Jean-Marie Le Pen
et ses héritiers siégeant sur ses bancs
un argument avancé alors vaut qu'on le
retienne certaines dispositions devaient
être votées car elles étaient
antionstitutionnelles et seraient donc
censurées par la suite nous vous nous
nous demandons parfois si vous vous
rendez compte du caractère planant de
certains de vos arguments ne croyez-vous
pas qu'un tel mépris pour nos règles
communes soit le signe d'un épuisement
de nos institutions la situation
politique don actuelle dont vous êtes un
sous-produit invite fortement à mettre
sur la table un changement
institutionnel une autre politique est
possible une autre République est
possible pour renouer avec la République
sociale avec notre belle devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité il est temps de
convoquer une constituante et de rédiger
la Constitution de la 6e république la
République de l'intervention citoyenne
du référendum révocatoire qui s'il était
mis en place permettrait au français de
tourner aux urnes alors que vous le
refusez obstinément en dépit de l'état
de crise permanent dans lequel vous
plongez le pays la République de
l'intérêt général enfin une République
où les ministres servent le peuple et
pas une oligarchie de plus en plus
déconnectée vivement un nouveau
gouvernement d'union populaire
organisant ce partage des richesses la
bifurcation écologique et le retour à la
démocratie dont notre pays a besoin nous
y sommes prêts avec détermination nous
préparons l'alternative à votre monde de
malheur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
emporter avec vous en guise
d'avertissement cette phrase du
philosophe Maurice Merl Penti qui disait
le pouvoir qu'on appelle légitime est
celui qui réussit à éviter le mépris et
la haine depuis 2017 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui vous n'avez réussi à éviter
ni l'un ni
l'autre je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente la parole est à présent
monsieur le Président marlex pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues au fond la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel rayant d'un trait plume
le travail du Parlement sur la loi
immigration et la crise quiexprime les
agriculteurs nous raconte la même
histoire celle de ces injonctions que le
peuple français ne supporte plus de
subir de la part tantôt de juges
supranationaux tantôt de juges nationaux
tantôt de technocrates bruxellois ou
parisiens mais ayant tous tous en commun
de ne jamais avoir de comptte à rendre
aux Français si la souveraineté
nationale peut à ce point être évité
contourné bafoué comment s'étonner alors
que la politique laisse à penser aux
yeux des Français qu'elle est devenue
une farce comment s'étonner qu'ils en
viennent à renverser la table dans ce
monde dans ce moment critique de notre
histoire dans cette démocratie en crise
qui est devenue la France chacun d'entre
nous se doit d'agir avec plus de sens
des responsabilités que jamais sur
l'immigration les Français exigent un
sursau vous leur livrez un tour de
pass-pe les Français en métropole ou en
Outremer n'en peuvent plus des discours
creux de vos catalogues La Redoute de
promesse jamais tenu vous osez nous dire
que depuis 2017 vous avez défendu vend
la souveraineté industrielle quelle
plaisanterie vous avez vendu Alstom
Alcatel Technip et vous laissez
démenteler àos comment vous croire vous
nous parlez d'alléger le fardeau des
normes pour les agriculteurs mais il y a
à peine plus d'un an au salon de
l'agriculture votre prédécesseur avait
déjà promis la fin de la
surtransposition des normes
environnementales et dans son univers
parallèle votre administration est en
train d'élaborer des cartes de
protection des tourbières qui vont
concerner 30 % de nos surfaces agricoles
voilà comment vous trompez les
cultivateurs et ce n'est pas en
supprimant Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au 4 arrêtés préfectoraux que vous allez
changer quoi que ce soit vous nous aviez
promis des prix de rémunération avec
égalim et en ce moment même l'actalis
propose au producteurs de lait un prix
de 40 centimes quand leur coût de
revient est à 48 centimes voilà comment
vous Bernez les éleveurs il y a un an
nous avons voté à l'unanimité de cette
assemblée calcul plus favorable pour la
retraite des agriculteurs depuis un an
vous faites tout pour que cette loi ne
soit pas appliquée il y a 8 mois nous
avons voté ici une résolution demandant
au gouvernement de s'opposer à la
ratification du Mercosur et il aura
fallu attendre hier pour que le
Président de la République Pride de
panique dans un Paris assiégé demande
enfin à Madame verleiden d'arrêter les
négociations dans ce même réveil brutal
on nous dit que président Macron serait
désormais prêt à partir en croisade
contre les 4 % de jacher de la PAC mais
que ne l'a-t-il fait plutôt la chaise
vide du général de Gaulle se faisait
mieux entendre que la chaise occupée du
président
Macron la politique ce n'est pas que de
la communication un catalogue d'annonces
sans que ni tête ce n'est pas du théâtre
c'est la vie des Français c'est le sort
de notre
pays vous entendre dire qu'on a décidé
de mettre l'agriculture au-dessus de de
tout fut un moment formidable j'ai
tellement eu envie d'y croire et puis je
me suis dit que cette phrase me
rappelait quelque chose et je me suis
souvenu que la semaine d'avant c'était
l'hôpital qui était la priorité absolue
et celle d'encore avant c'était l'école
et la semaine prochaine ce sera autre
chose peut-être l'écologie la culture et
alors tant pis pour l'agriculture sur la
crise agricole comme sur l'immigration
les Français ne se contenteront pas
d'une Story sur Instagram Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ou d'une vidéo TikTok
autour d'une botte de paille ils veulent
des résultats dans la vraie vie je vous
le dis très clairement Monsieur le
Premier Ministre tant que les réponses
ne seront pas là nous ne vous lâcherons
pas la terrible réalité c'est qu'après 7
ans d'agitation fiévreuse à coup
d'annonce choc de grand plan de grands
débats d'entretien de sie il ne s'est
rien passé vous êtes passé sur les maots
du pays comme des courants d'air après 7
ans de pouvoir absolu à vous écouter
vous semblez seulement seulement
découvrir le pays mais les crises
sociales se succède le pays est exangle
fracturé révolté ces crises comme celle
des gilets jaunes ont toutes en commun
que vous ne les voyez jamais venir parce
que vous n'êtes pas dans la vraie vie
des
Français votre politique
nentthousiasme en réalité que ceux qui
n'attendent rien de la politique c'estes
premiers de cord cher au président qui
depuis longtemps se sont émancipé et
pensent ne plus avoir grand-chose en
commun avec le reste du peuple français
mais France qui a le plus besoin d'un
pouvoir qui la protège d'une concurrence
déloyale agriculteur ouvrier patron de
petites industries la France qui a le
plus besoin de servicees publics
d'écoles d'hôupitaux la France qui n'a
plus de médecin la France qui a besoin
que l'on remette de l'ordre qu'on
enferme ces dealers qui menacent ses
enfants celle-là vous ne la voyez pas
vous ne l'entendez pas et vous la
laissez s'enfoncer dans la colère
comment s'en étonner de la part d'un
président pour qui il y a deux
catégories de français ceux qui ont
réussi et ceux qui ne sont
rien monsieur le monsieur le Premier
ministre derrière la communication la
réalité c'est l'échec de ce 7 années de
pouvoir du Président de la République
les résultats sont là monsieur le maire
depuis 7 ans en rarqué de son empreinte
ou plutôt de ses empreuns son passage au
ministère des Finances creusant avec une
assid avec assiduité une dette habysale
de 3088 milliards d'euros ce sont 900
milliards d'euros de plus qu'à la fin du
quinquen de François Hollande en 2023 le
déficit est pire que prévu 173 milliards
d'euros et vous osez venir nous dire que
vous faites preuve d'une responsabilité
exemplaire en matière de finances
publiqu de qui vous moquez-vous et tout
ça pour quel résultat la croissance est
en berne 0,8 % 2023 et pas mieux pour
2024 le pouvoir d'achat des Français est
encore pe plus encore un peu plus
attaqué par l'inflation et les années
que vous aurez perdu par vos aements sur
le nucléaire à faire du suivisme
derrière les écologistes vous place
désormais dans une situation abérrente
où vous allez à la fois augmenter la
facture des ménages et faire perdre à
nos entreprises leur dernier avantage de
compétitivité au ministère de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin accueille
plus de 500000 étrangers par an c'est en
moyenne sous le septena Macron deux fois
plus que sous le quinquena de Nicolas
Sarkozy quant à l'insécurité nous en
sommes à 300 62000 coups et blessures en
2023 60 % de plus qu'en 2017 depuis 50
ans la France n'a jamais enregistré
autant d'homicide ou de tentativ
d'omicide magnifique record pour votre
gouvernement en matière d'éducation vous
savez la merre des batailles la France
s'effondre au classement PISA 10e dans
les années 2000 elle est aujourd'hui 23e
en Scien et en math 25e en lecture vous
êtes au pouvoir depuis 7 ans c'est votre
bilan
vous avez également créé une crise du
logement sans précédent on ne construit
plus les Français ont de plus en plus de
difficultés à accéder à la propriété
votre système ma prime renove réussit
l'exploit de rendre les travaux
d'isolation désormais inaccessible à la
fois aux classes moyennees jugé trop
riche et au foyers les plus modestes
incapable évidemment de financer des
rénovation globas cette crise est telle
qu'on voit désormais en France en 2024
des salariés dorm dans leur voiture
alors quand vous nous parlez de choc
d'offre de simplification des normes
d'accélération des procédures
permettez-nous de penser que c'est un
peu court enfin le bilan des anné Macron
c'est aussi un concernant
affaiblissement de la parole de la
France à l'internationale cette
singularité française que nous
chérissions tous ici a fait les frais
des attermoims des paroles maladroites
ou des gestes déplacés des coupes comm
sans lendemain du président de la
République renvoyer sans ménagement
d'Afrique décrédibilisé au Liban snobé
au Maroc inaudible sur la guerre en
Ukraine hésitant sur Israël la lucidité
impose de reconnaître que quelques chose
s'est brisé de l'image de notre pays aux
yeux du monde Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous nous auriez demandé notre
confiance après ces 7 années de pouvoir
nous n'aurions évidemment pas pu vous la
donner mais nous ne vous empêcherons pas
d'agir AJE besoin de rappeler que sans
notre soutien les rares réformes de
redressement de ce pays retraite RSA
n'aurait pas vu le jour au contraire au
contraire nous vous pressons d'agir sans
délai pour les agriculteurs pour
reprendre le contrôle vraiment de notre
immigration pour faire vraiment
respecter la loi de la République
partout sur notre territoire nous
l'avons bien compris ce remanement
ministériel vise davantage à infléchir
le cours des sondages que de l'histoire
ce n'est pourtant pas la communication
qui fera la réussite de ce gouvernement
c'est sa capacité à écouter et à
respecter les Français leurs attentes
français que nous représentons tous ici
dans cet hémicycle dans l'intérêt du
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre tâchez
de faire mieux que ce qui vous a demandé
par le président et souvenez-vous que la
durée de vie de votre gouvernement ne
dépend pas que du président de la
République mais aussi de cette Assemblée
nationale où vous êtes minoritaire et
dont vous n'aurez pas la
confiance merci beaucoup monsieur
président la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe neigelen pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre M et
territoire madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues notre pays
est en crise les Français sont plus que
jamais en attente de réponse concrète à
leurs préoccupation sans posture
politicienne mais avec des actes la
première de ces préoccupations la santé
on peut saluer certaines mesures
notamment le Ségure de la santé mais
honnêtement la transformation du numerus
closus en numérus apertus n'a rien
changé à l'offre de soins qui reste
totalement insuffisante dans un grand
nombre de nos territoires cela fait des
années que les députés de notre groupe
vous alertent sur la question l'hôpital
public est en crise la médecine de ville
est en crise en somme c'est tout notre
système de santé qui se délabre et
pourtant des solutions simples sont
envisageables la passerelle que vous
avez proposé pour les infirmières est
intéressante mais nous vous proposons
aussi de faciliter l'intégration en
étude de médecine et d'augmenter
drastiquement le nombre d'étudiants il
s'agit également de mieux valoriser les
personnel de santé chevie indispensable
à la qualité des soins et de
l'accompagnement dans la dignité de nos
aînés l'autre grand chantier l'éducation
nationale là aussi toutes les inégalités
doivent être traitées notamment dans les
territoires ruraux qui voient leur
classe fermé tandis qu'elles ont été
dédoublées dans les REP et REP plus ce
dédoublement est une bonne chose dans
ces territoire urbain mais il faut dans
une logique d'équivalence baisser les
seuils amenant à la fermeture de classe
en zone rural le manque d'attractivité
dans cette profession est stigmatisé par
une nouvelle baisse en 2024 du nombre
d'inscrit au concours externe par
rapport à 2023 la perte de pouvoir
d'achat subi par les enseignants depuis
plus de 20 ans en est une des raisons
sur laquelle il faut continuer à avancer
de plus toujours sur la partie éducation
et pour une véritable inclusion scolaire
il faut Monsieur le Premier Ministre
drastiquement augmenter le nombre
d'aesh la place de la France dans le
monde est-elle aussi capitale notre
environnement proche est marqué par de
très fortes instabilités notre pays doit
continuer à faire entendre et respecter
sa voix singulière que cela soit
diplomatiquement cultur ellement ou
commercialement ainsi qu'à défendre
l'autonomie stratégique européenne un
beau défi international est devant nous
c'est celui de la bonne organisation des
Jeux Olympiques et par extension de leur
sécurisation la mobilisation
l'information la rémunération des forces
de l'ordre seront crucial crucial pour
leur bonne organisation sur cette
question sécuritaire tous nos
territoires sont touchés nous l'avons vu
lors des émeutes de juinen dernier
attention à ce que nos territoires les
plus en tension et notamment nreemè ne
soient pas dépossédés de leurs forces de
l'ordre on observe actuellement à
Mayotte un blocage total de lî qui doit
nous alerter et qui appelle à de
nouveaux renfort sur les questions
économiques beaucoup reste à faire un
constat est partagé par nos agriculteurs
et nos dirigeants d'entreprise celui du
poids des normes en 2017 il avait été
annoncé pour toute loi voter on en
supprimera deux Monsieur le Premier
Ministre remettez cela à l'ordre du jour
simplifier toutes les démarches pour nos
entreprises PME TPE comme pour nos
agriculteurs arrêtons la
surtransposition des normes le monde de
l'entreprise et des agriculteurs est
alerte aussi sur la transmission et la
reprise d'activité aujourd'hui plus de
50 % des agriculteurs ont plus de 50 ans
pour que nos notre agriculture vive il
est primordial que nos agriculteurs
vivent et transmettent leur exploitation
ils doivent pouvoir obtenir des prêts
spécifique de carrière sur 25 ans et des
beau à long terme qui permettra d'avoir
de la visibilité nous avons besoin d'une
loi d'orientation agricole musclée et
qui sorte rapidement avec des objectifs
clairs sur l'installation des jeunes et
leur rémunération est absolument
nécessaire enfin et c'est primordial
n'aortons pas l'agriture l'agriculture
que nous ne voulons pas produire chez
nous sortons les sujets agricoles comme
monnaie d'échange de tous les accords
commerciaux entre l'Union européenne et
les pays-tiers il y aurait bien d'autres
sujets à traiter mais 5 minutes et bien
entendu beaucoup trop court Monsieur le
Premier Ministre énormément de
problématiques sont sur la table elles
demandent des réponses concrète et sans
demi-mesure nous serons exigeants et
nous saurons dire quand les propositions
nous paraîtront déconnectées et n'allant
pas dans le sens de l'intérêt de nos
territoires et des Français et des
Français qui les composent mais notre
groupe parlementaire comme à son
habitude se montrera pragmatique dans
l'évaluation des solutions proposées
dans un parlement sans majorité absolue
il continuera à être force de
propositions à avec des solutions
concrètes sur les réformes à mener et
les carences constatées nous espérons
que nous serons entendu la situation
politique dans notre pays le command je
vous remercie monsieur
néigelen la parole est à Monsieur
duponteignan pour une durée de 5
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur
Monsieur le Premier Ministre chers
collègues vous entrez dans le livre des
records non pas parce que vous êtes le
plus jeune premier ministre mais parce
que vous êtes le nouveau Premier
ministre du président de tous les
tristes records record d'endettement
avec 788 milliards supplémentaires
depuis 2017 record de déficit commercial
record de déficit budgétaire avec en
2023 presque le montant de 2020 record
d'immigration avec deux fois plus de
séjour de premier titre de séjour record
d'insécurité avec plus 63 % de cout et
blessure depuis 2017 et bien sûr record
d'impopularité car on ne peut pas
éternellement confondre présidence
également confondre présidence de la
République et agence de
communication vous devez vivre monsieur
le Premier ministre dans le même monde
parallèle qu'Emmanuel Macron pour avoir
osé cet après-midi qualifier son bilan
de concret tangible et solide je
comprends mieux pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
vous a choisi j'attendais un premier
ministre j'ai découvert un porte-parole
un seul discours aura donc suffit pour
comprendre que votre nomination ne
changera rien et cela pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est que le
président Emmanuel Macron le vrai
Premier ministre comme sa conférence de
presse l'a démontré comment allez-vous
conforter les classes moyennes alors
qu'avant même ce discours de politique
générale Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
lui-même l'augmentation des franchises
sur les médicaments et Bruno lomer
l'augmentation du tarif de
l'électricité dans un autre domaine
celui de l'éducation nationale comment
allez-vous pouvoir répondre à toutes les
demandes de l'Élysée cours de théâtre
cours de sport instruction civique à des
élèves qui ont besoin avant tout
d'apprendre à lire en matière de
sécurité comment allez-vous faire
baisser la délinquence en conservant un
garde d'essau et une politique
judiciaire profondément laxiste et en
étant fier de laisser détricoter une loi
sur l'immigration qui était déjà bien
insuffisante enfin dans le domaine du
logement vous ne manquez pas de culot
pour annoncer un choc de l'offre alors
que depuis 2017 vous avez
systématiquement saboter tous les
mécanismes d'aide au logement la seconde
raison pour laquelle vous êtes condamné
à parler dans le vide à agiter des
éléments de langage éternellement
ressassés depuis 2017 et que si le
premier ministre est à l'Élysée le vrai
président est malheureusement à
Bruxelles c'est Madame Van derleyen qui
vous donne des ordres matin midi et soir
preuve en est mes chers collègues la
commission européenne vient d'annoncer à
l'instant des pêchesretaire que vous
pouvez vous procurer que les
négociations avec le
mercosour continuaient bien infligeant
un nouveau camouflé à l'Élysée qui
prétendait hier qu'elles étaient
stoppées de même au moment où vous
tentiez d'éteindre l'incendie agricole
en tenant un discours assis sur une
botte de foin un consultant en
communication avait vous dû vous
suggérer que cela ferait bien et les
députés européens renaissance après
avoir déjà approuvé la nouvelle Pâque et
ces achers votaient en faveur de
l'accord de libre échange avec le Chili
après ce avec la Nouvelle-Zélande avec
le Kenya avec le Vietnam enfin enfin
vous avez préféré ça vous fait rire
donner des gages au gouvernement
allemand plutôt que de baisser le tarif
de l'électricité en sortant du marché
européen comme ont su le faire l'Espagne
et le Portugal alors pour faire oublier
vos doubl discours successifs vous êtes
condamné à multiplier les effets
d'annonce vous nous avez livré cet
après-midi un concours un catalogue de
mesurettes avanthier l'éducation était
au-dessus de tout hier c'était
l'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est le
travail en définitive vous me faites
penser à ces jongleurs d'assiette qui
dans les cirques sont obligés d'en
ajouter toujours plus pour tenir en
haleine le spectateur jusqu'au jour où
patata elle se toutes ce moment est
proche car les Français ne se portent
plus les fausses promesses les
injonction contradictoire le manque de
sérieux et de maturité dans la conduite
de l'État la disparition de la
souveraineté populaire sans majorité
dans cet hémicycle vous serez obligé
comme votre prédécesseur de multiplier
jusqu'à plus soif les 493 et plutôt une
motion de censure nous libérera de cette
ma a pièces de théâtre pour avec de
nouvelles élections législatives
permettre au peuple d'arbitrer et plus
vite la souffrance des Français la nôtre
et la vôtre Monsieur le Premier Ministre
seront
abrégés je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre
merci madame la Présidente je ne serai
pas très
long manifestement une partie des
interventions qui ont succédé à ma prise
de parole avait été écrite avant ma
prise de parole c'est le jeu on sait
comment ça fonctionne je voulais revenir
sur quelques points qui m'ont semblé
importants évidemment notamment
s'agissant de nos
agriculteurs j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire tout à l'heure dans les T prochains
jours nous annoncerons de nouvelles
mesures en soutien à nos agriculteurs
nous avons échangé vous le savez avec
leurs représentants pendant 3h30 hier il
y a des discussions continu qui se
poursuivent avec eux entre nos équipes
entre nous pour avancer et je sais que
c'est attendu et je sais que c'est
attendu depuis longtemps pour certaines
d'entre elles je veux revenir sur
certains points qui ont été évoqués dire
à Monsieur marlex que sur la question
des tourbières des zones humides j'ai
bien annoncé vendredi dernier que je
donnais consigne à ensemble des préfets
de mettre ce travail en pause le temps
de revoir les choses avec les
représentants des agriculteurs j'ai bien
mesuré le malaise qui existait autour de
cette question sur la question des
surtranspositions il y a un engagement
qui a été pris par le président en 2017
qui a été tenu pas d'interdiction sans
solution un projet de loi et ça n'a pas
été simple je me souviens des débats
politiques qui sont intervenus dans cet
hémicycle nous avons assumé précisément
sur la betterave d'autoriser de de
réautoriser les néonicotinoïdes parce
que la filière vave était en train de
couler les néonicotinoïdes pour la
betterave avaiit été interdit par la
majorité sous François Hollande sans
sans qu'à l'époque la majorité se
préoccupe une seule seconde de savoir
s'il y avait des solutions de
substitution nous sommes élus en 2017 on
se rend compte qu'il y a pas de
substitution on a assumé de réautoriser
les néonicotinoïdes pour la filière
betterve qui sinon serait se serait
écroulé et moi j'assume de dire j'assume
de dire
que quand vous avez à l'initiative d'une
agence si indépendante soit-elle une
décision de de d'interdiction d'une
molécule sans se préoccuper de savoir ce
qui se passe au niveau européen et ce
qui est décidé au niveau européen c'est
un problème j'assume de le dire et donc
nous devons regarder comment nous avons
une organisation qui fonctionne mieux de
ce point de vue-l sur égalim je suis de
très près et nous suivons de très près
avec mes ministres avec Bruno le
notamment on en parlait aussi hier avec
les organisations d'agriculteurs les
discussions qui sont en cours notamment
sur le lait que vous avez évoqué moi je
veux simplement rappeler qu'avant les
lois égalim c'est la loi LME qui
s'appliquait qui donnait les pleins
pouvoirs à la grande distribution et je
nentends pas un seul agriculteur nous
dire que les lois à Galim n'ont pas
constitué un progrès ou qu'il faudrait
revenir en arrière ce qu'il nous disent
ce qu'il nous disent c'est qu'il faut
améliorer le fonctionnement des galimes
il faut améliorer le fonctionnement des
galimes faire davantage de contrôle et
prendre des mesures on en a parlé aussi
hier avec les organisations
d'agriculteurs des mesures pour la
rendre plus efficace notamment du point
de vue évidemment de la rémunération de
nos agriculteurs mais nous sommes prêts
vraiment prêts à le faire sur les
jachers ça fait des mois que Marc fenau
est mobilisé auprès de la Commission
européenne on a rallié 22 pays européens
autour de nous et je le dis je crois que
nous allons obtenir cette semaine je
l'espère en tout cas mais j'ai vu des
signaux y compris médiatiques de la
commission aujourd'hui nous nous allons
obtenir une nouvelle dérogation sur le
sujet et à ce propos je veux dire au
rassemblement national et à Madame Le
Pen par que vous avez vous-même mis en
avant le sujet des votes au Parlement
européen que quand vous dénoncez les
nouvelles règles sur les jachers elles
sont issues des nouvelles règles de la
PAC que vos députés au Parlement
européen ont voté vos députés au
Parlement européen ont voté pour si si
c'est la réalité je je je vous votez
vous votez les règles de la vous critiz
mais vous ne votez pas les budets de la
PAC que vous demandez c'est une
incohérence absolue c'est à se demander
si vos députés savent ce qu'il votent au
niveau européen c'est à se demander si
sincèrement vos députés savent ce qu'il
vote parce que la réalité c'est que vous
nous parlez de protection vous nous
parlez d'indépendance vous nous parlez
de notre industrie nous avons porté au
niveau européen une taxe carbone aux
frontières ça faisit 20 ans que
notamment dans l'industrie en Europe on
se battait pour une taxe carbone aux
frontières vos députés ne l'ont pas voté
qu'on est de l'acier chinois qui arrive
au même prix que l'acier européen ça n'a
pas l'air de vous poser le moindre
problème nous avons assumé de porter ce
mécanisme européen à nos frontières vous
venez nous déclarer ici et dans les
médias qu'il faut renoncer aux
exportations aux échanges internationaux
à tout accord de libre échange vous irez
expliquer à nos éleveurs de porc en
Bretagne qui exportent notamment 30 % de
leur production et qui exporte en Chine
vous irez l'expliquer à nos viticulteurs
à ceux qui produisent du cognac à ceux
qui produisent des produits qui sont
massivement exporté vous irez
l'expliquer Madame Le Pen ça a l'air de
vous déranger que je vous mette en face
malheureusement de la réalité vous irit
expliquer à nos producteurs laitiers qui
exportent massivement là aussi pour 4
milliards en dehors de l'Union
Européenne notamment via le CTA que vous
appelez à dénoncer vous irez leur
expliquer nous nous sommes cohérents
quand un accord est bon et et de dire
l'engagement qui est le nôtre qui est
celui du président de la République en
ce moment même au niveau européen et ça
sera encore le cas jeudi dans le cadre
du Conseil européen de faire progresser
les choses au service de notre
agriculture évidemment que c'est dur
évidemment que c'est difficile
évidemment qu'il y a un certain nombre
de cas on narrive pas à convaincre tout
le monde enener tout le monde autour
genou c'est ça la difficulté la solution
de facilité c'est la vôre c'est de dire
on s'oppose à tout mais à la fin ça fait
progresser quoi ça fait progresser quoi
pour nos
agriculteurs ça leur permet quoi
oui je me tourne aussi vers vous c'est
aussi la solution qui est la vôtre
pardon mais vous avez là-dessus une
forme de cohérence aussi et vous vous
rejoignez dans la posture nous on
continuera à se battre pour nos
agriculteurs nous aurons l'occasion avec
Marc F d'annoncer des choses très
concrètes dans les heures et dans les
jours qui viennent nous serons
rendez-vous pour soutenir nos
agriculteurs et heureusement que nous
sommes là pour les accompagner merci
beaucoup monsieur le Premier ministre le
débat est clos je vous propose une
suspension de 5 minutes et nous
reprendrons sur le
vote